auquel on ne peut répondre mais
matériellement ça ne va pas tenir dans
le temps qui était prévu à l'origine
point ça ne doit pas tenir
ça s'est terminé à 5 heures du matin en
commission avec une minute par
amendement est pas mal de groupes qui
aujourd'hui dans l'assemblée discute et
des bas des amendements et c'est normal
et en partie au fur et à mesure donc il
suffit de calculer de manière
mathématique
ça ne se terminera pas minuit donc il
faut qu'à partir de là on règle les
questions est-ce que ça dure toute la
nuit mais à mon avis même jusqu'à cinq
ou six heures du matin ça ne tiendra pas
non plus donc la demande qui était toute
à l'heure de réunir en urgence
maintenant la conférence des présidents
pour faire en sorte qu'il ya un ordre du
jour qui permettent de respecter les
débats me semble nécessaire
là on va dans le mur et on sachant qu'on
va dans le mur merci monsieur convient
et merci à monsieur le fur pour cette
approbation je boive poste je vous
propose de toute façon va pas jouer à ce
petit jeu-là jeu
j'attendrai les boues monsieur
bernalicis je retire le mot je vous avez
compris ce qu'il en est et vous n'êtes
pas obligé de prendre ce ton pour me
parler d'accord bon alors deuxième chose
je dis je je dis à l'instant je dis
instant que je réunirai c'était une une
faveur et j'entends ce qui a été dit à
l'instant pas ça me paraît pertinent je
réunirai à un moment les présidents de
groupe où je ferai passer un message au
président de boutons travaux responsable
de groupe pour que tout le monde et la
même information au même moment
voilà c'est l'engagement que je peux
prendre après je ne maîtrise pas je suis
vice-président je ne maîtrise pas le
déroulé nos travaux donc je vous propose
qu'on reprenne l'examen des amendements
et on le fasse dans un esprit qui
avaient été définis que cet après midi
comme devant être apaisé le 141 me
gosselin s'il vous plaît l'apaisement il
est bien là monsieur le président n'y a
pas d' attaques personnelles ni de
remise en cause et je défends mon
amendement en même temps comme ça il n'y
a pas de difficultés particulières ni de
rappel au règlement il n'y a pas de
difficulté ni d'anicroches ni de remise
en cause de la présidence simplement
nous regrettons qu'à l'heure où nous
reprenons nos travaux
pour peut-être toute la nuit avec près
de mille amendements nous ne sachions
encore pas comment on va gérer
l'ensemble
voilà c'est ça paraît du b à ba c'est
une question simple vraiment de béotiens
et je m'étonne qu'effectivement à cette
question simple et bonne puisque vous
l'avez ainsi qualifiés il n'y a pas de
réponse
voilà bref en tout cas nous sommes
concentrés sur ces mesures sanitaires
dont les délais sont à nouveau allongé
et il me semble ici à nouveau que nous
devons avoir une clause de revoyure qui
permettent à l'assemblée au parlement
dans son ensemble de pouvoir se
prononcer régulièrement vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises que nous nous étions
depuis 18 mois a réuni des dizaines
voire des centaines d'heures c'est vrai
personne ne peut le contester et c'est
heureux du reste
sauf à considérer les propos du ministre
de la santé hier soir qui à plusieurs
reprises nous a dit que s'il n'en tenait
qu'à lui il ne il se passerait du
parlement mais ça on l'a bien compris
depuis longtemps
il l'a dit à plusieurs reprises son idée
c'était sans doute de vouloir accélérer
les choses
on ne peut pas dire qu'on accélère les
choses ou qu'on n'aille à l'encontre des
choses puisque on est réuni au coup par
coup et c'est bien ce qu'on vous
reproche de ne pas avoir de clause de
revoyure d'avoir dans le temps la
possibilité de se retrouver sauf sous la
pression des événements
il faut qu'il y ait une quatrième vague
et avant une 3e et avant ce qu'on
qualifiait de seconde à énoncer pas une
seconde c'est une deuxième pas de bol
etc etc alors qu'il suffirait entre
guillemets de dire tous les trois mois
on se retrouve sa apaiserait les débats
je peux vous assurer qu'en réalité on
perdrait moins de temps ça serait plus
démocratique beaucoup plus clair
beaucoup plus transparent voilà pourquoi
nous proposons la date du 31 octobre à
la place du 31 décembre
merci amendements identiques mais ses
boutons le 234e oui merci monsieur
président oui c'est le même amendement
que notre collègue au sein mais à mon
tour je voudrais m'étonner les
conditions d'examen du texte on a déjà
vu les conditions aberrante
de la commission des lois qui s'est fini
à 5h10 ce matin le un temps pour déposer
des amendements très court vous avez pu
voir durant cet après midi que nous
avons déposé des amendements pour aller
au fond des choses pas du tout dans une
logique d'obstruction mais
d'approfondissement du texte nous
attendons sur beaucoup de sujets les
réponses des ministres
pourquoi la date du 2 juin 2021 pour
pouvoir prendre certains décrets
questions restées sans réponse pourquoi
est-ce que le pass sanitaire est le même
que celui qui existe pour les
établissements nocturnes de notre
collègue blanchet questions restées sans
réponse donc on voit que s'il y a une
mauvaise volonté elle est manifestement
du côté du gouvernement qui ne répond
pas à nos question est donc comment dans
quelles conditions on peut travailler
nous partons la deux avec 985
amendements sans avoir de programme de
travail ce sont vraiment des conditions
consternante pour un texte encore une
fois qui est sensible qui est important
on se rend compte de la sensibilité dans
la population mais vraiment la position
de l'exécutif et de la majorité est
incompréhensible
merci monsieur votre monsieur mbaye le
1040 chiche n'est pas défendu dans cette
discussion commune
j'indique que sur le 148 que nous allons
examiner un instant et qui va être
inquiet par monsieur gosselin il ya
également un scrutin public
il est annoncé l'enceinte de l'assemblée
monsieur gosselin oui toujours le même
état d'esprit c'est permettre une clause
de revoyure gpad
et rouler l'ensemble des arguments à
chaque fois ce sont les mêmes nous
voulons non pas gagner du temps ça
n'aurait pas de sens de vouloir à tout
prix gagner quinze jours un mois mais
c'est simplement permettre un débat
serein et organisé j'insiste sur ce
point
organiser les conditions du débat et ne
pas se laisser basculer par les
événements et les différentes vagues de
crise merci le 235 monsieur breton
défendu le 1103 ne me semble pas défendu
monsieur le rapporteur a je n'ai pas vu
monsieur mathias d'un oui oui je vous
cherchez le 1103 me fait mal quand un
monsieur le vrai le président monsieur
magri mais les messieurs collègues
cet amendement vise à recourir à va
forcir deux mois la durée de la période
transitoire de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
un délai de 4 mois semble en effet
largement suffisant et donc si l'une ce
n'était pas le cas
le gouvernement pourrait toujours serait
toujours en mesure de revenir devant le
parlement pour en débattre
alors je voulais ajouter que le pass
annie terre tels qu'ils figurent dans le
présent texte est une méthode brutale
pour imposer à tous la vaccination
le pass sanitaires imposées aussi
brutalement dans les outre-mer notamment
en guadeloupe et en martinique alors que
nous avons 26 un taux de chômage de 25%
40% pour les jeunes la plupart les
jeunes sont aujourd'hui deux au bord des
routes
c'est là qu'ils se réunissent par
ailleurs nous recevons aujourd'hui du
tout les touristes qui font la fête dans
les hôtels il me semble difficile de
prises et notamment les restaurateurs de
cet espace parce que vous savez que la
plupart des restaurants sont dans des
espaces ouverts donc appliqués
brutalement se passe à lutter dès
aujourd'hui quasiment c'est-à-dire de
l'adoption du texte nous semblait tout à
totalement incohérent il ne va pas dans
le sens
ce désintérêt de cette population de ses
aspirations de sa culture dans la mesure
où on s'attend à ce qu'il ya des mesures
qui soient prises et qui soit différente
et inconsciente à sion par conséquent
ils nous demandent à ce que il ya une
large concertation pour que la question
du passage du ter ne semble pas dans un
département dans un pays dans une région
où les gens se vaccine peu ne semble pas
simplement fait pour imposer une
vaccination obligatoire
merci beaucoup merci monsieur magasin
monsieur le rapporteur merci monsieur le
président par cohérence avec le vote sur
l'année 1 3 c'est-à-dire maintien du 31
décembre
avis défavorable sur cet amendement
merci messieurs mesdames et messieurs
les députés
le pass sanitaires il s'agit bien du
passé ni terre est un outil qui doit
nous permettre en cas de flambées
épidémiques
nous y sommes presque de ne pas fermer
des établissements recevant du public
pour tout le monde mais de permettre aux
commerçants aux restaurateurs aux musées
aux bâtiments nationaux aux éléments
culturels festifs sportifs de rester
cette fois ci ouvert quel est le
fondement scientifique du pass
sanitaires toutes les études nous
montrent que s'il y avait une flambée
épidémique
si nous fermions la totalité des
établissements recevant du public pour
tous les français nous aurions le même
impact sur l'épidémie est sûre les
hôpitaux que si nous en laissions
l'accès libre aux personnes qui sont
vaccinées
le pass sanitaire est donc l'outil par
lequel nous ne devrions pas être
contraints de fermer les établissements
recevant du public c'est à dire nous ne
devrions pas être contraints de
reconfirmer le pays
vous avez raison de souligner qu' un
certain nombre de français qui ne sont
pas encore vaccinés et nous faisons tout
pour les mobiliser et nous mettons à
disposition des centres les médecins les
pharmaciens pour que le plus grand
nombre d'entre eux puissent vacciner
dans les meilleurs délais
j'entends par ici que le pass à lithaire
serait une forme de punition ou un
supplément d'âme visant à empêcher les
uns les autres d'aller et venir je vous
dis que c'est exactement l'inversé
comprenez-moi bien parce que vous
demander ce qu'on se revoit dans trois
mois monsieur gosselin moi j'ai aucune
difficulté j'étais là il ya un mois et
demi en vous disant que septembre ça
paraissait cours en vous disant que
septembre ça me paraissait cours je
reviendrai autant de fois qu'il le faut
et je me suis engagé c'est le 10e ou 11e
texte que nous voyons ensemble le pass
sanitaire n'est pas une punition qui
vise à fermer l'accès à des gens c'est
de passer à lithaire est le seul moyen
par lequel nous pouvons éviter de fermer
la totalité des établissements recevant
du public s'il ya une flambée épidémique
je vous le redis donc le pas sali terne
a du sens que temps que toute la
population n'est pas vacciné ricciotti
disais tout à l'heure le passe à
lithaire ce sera bien quand tout le
monde aura été vaccinées mais j'ai une
bonne nouvelle monsieur ciotti
par définition si tout le monde est
vacciné il ya plus de passes parce que
si tout le monde est vacciné ya plus de
virus ça veut dire qu'il ya deux
éléments qu'il faut comprendre le
premier élément c'est qu'il y a urgence
le 1er janvier monsieur rifan je vais
vous donner tout à l'heure la parole et
je crois qu'à 36 ce soir je pas ralentir
les débats et que chacun puisse contre
mexique on joue ensuite on nous accuse
pas d'expliquer de ne pas expliquer les
choses il ya urgence à appliquer je sais
cordier votre masque s'il vous plaît
arrêtez d interpellation tout le temps
là l'urgence il ya mais tout le temps
tout le temps vous demandait de répondre
je me lève sans arrêt vous êtes sans
arrêt vous électives et sans arrière
[Applaudissements]
après j'aimerais soir j'ai pu parler me
dit et vous allez dire que le ministre
parle pas il ya urgence à appliquer le
passe à lithaire pourquoi je disais
presque en terre de provocation monsieur
gosselin vous avez raison que si j'avais
pu faire le pas sanitaires sans passer
par la loi
je l'aurais fait parce qu'il ya urgence
parce qu'il ya 21 mille cas aujourd'hui
18 milles hier tiendra peut-être 25000
demain et que les courbes hospitalière
commence à monter et que plus nous
tardons appliquer ce dispositif puis
nous tardons dans les jours que nous
passons ici dans les hémicycles avec
1000 amendements sur ce texte
c'est très légitime d'en débattre je
vous dit juste c'est très légitime d'en
débattre
je vous dis qu'il ya une urgence
sanitaire dans notre pays et que plus
nous tardons que plus nous tarde aurait
trempa se passe à lithaire et ce n'est
pas un chantage ce n'est pas une
prophétie c'est ce que je vous dis ce
que nous disent les scientifiques plus
nous risquons de nous retrouver au pied
d'un mur épidémique nécessitant de
prendre des mesures que ni vous ni nous
ne souhaitons prendre pour protéger la
vie des français c'est le contexte et je
veux que vous soyez parfaitement clair
avec ça vous avez le droit de l'assumer
mais ne dit pas pesé pas que vous serez
pas informés alors si tu le passes à
lithaire nous n'aurons plus besoin
dès lors que nous aurons vacciner les
gens donc ça veut dire que le pass à
lithaire plutôt peut le supprimer
plus tôt on supprimera et je vous le dis
dès lors qu'on aura atteint à l'immunité
collective et où dès lors que le virus
ne sera plus en circulation massive dans
le pays
nous n'aurons plus besoin du pass
sanitaires donc je ne pense pas hélas
que ce sera au 31 octobre
peut-être ce serait formidable je pense
qu'il ya plus de chances que ce soit au
cours du mois de décembre que les choses
pourront être je l'espère totalement
tasse et donc nous vous demandons ce
délai pour ne pas nous remettre en péril
vous le remettre en danger
je vous le dis si la loi avait été votée
avait été votée nous aurions étendu le
passe à lithaire aux bars et restaurants
à l'heure à laquelle je vous parle nous
l'avons fait par décret ce que nous
pouvions faire nous avons besoin de la
loi et je vous le redis je vous le redis
parce que je suis sans arrêt interpellé
ici parce que vous nous accusez de
manqué d'anticipation
il ya aujourd'hui urgence merci monsieur
le ministre
alors
[Applaudissements]
conformément à notre règlement je
prendrai deux orateurs monsieur rixheim
ciotti et on procédera au vote de ces
amendements
la manière dont vous présentez les
choses monsieur le ministre est
mensongère et je pense que c'est une
erreur à l'égard des français de
d'affiché de pareilles certitudes vous
présenter aujourd'hui le vaccin comme un
remède miracle et à partir du moment où
tout le monde sera vacciné y aura plus
de problème alors que vous savez très
bien que dans des pays où il ya au
niveau de vaccination que ça soit israël
ou l'angleterre
il ya des risques de confinement il ya
des grandes difficultés parce que le
vaccin n'est pas un remède miracle
aujourd'hui il ya des virologues
néerlandais qui alerte sur le fait qu'
évidemment le vaccin le virus continue à
se propager
malgré le vaccin dire que c'est un outil
dans la boîte à outils face au co vice
c'est une chose
dire que c'est un remède miracle c'est
tromper les parlementaires et s'est
trompé les français aujourd'hui ça n'est
pas un remède miracle c'est un outil un
outil est un intéressant mais c'est un
outil
ensuite le monsieur gosselin vous avez
proposé qu'on se revoit plus rapidement
moi j'ai des amendements on a des
amendements pour dire c'est toutes les
semaines qui devrait y avoir un débat
dans cet hémicycle sur les mesures à
prendre face au co vide
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi
c'est nul ce qu'ils font pourquoi scanu
ce que le président fait ce que le
gouvernement fait parce que c'est
toujours dans l'urgence était toujours
dans la solitude c'est à dire qu'il ya
une absence de confiance dans
l'intelligence collective qu'on pourra
avoir pour amener d'autres solutions on
nous a dit pendant des mois
c'est le confinement ou la mort c'est
leur confinement ou la mort c'est
l'heureux confinement ou la mort et ce
soir on nous dit
c'est le pass sanitaires ou la mort
c'est pas vrai il ya des tas de
solutions qu'on pourrait imaginer
ensemble
pourquoi n'y a pas des aérateurs partout
comment on fait pour les mettre en
oeuvre pour toi y'a pas libre pourquoi
n'y a pas des brigades mobiles pour
aller chercher les gens allaient mercier
ne sont pas aujourd'hui vacciner this on
arrive pourquoi
merci monsieur ciotti merci monsieur le
président en quelques mots simplement
pour répondre à monsieur le ministre
parce que vous avez une faculté de
travestir les propos et la réalité
vous avez aussi une faculté de changer
d'avis et ça c'est un mérite qu'on peut
vous reconnaitre je voudrais ce soir je
voudrais ce soir à ce stade vous citez
monsieur le ministre
c'était il ya trois mois au sénat vous
soulignez vous disiez avec beaucoup de
conviction ce qui est toujours votre cas
mais le problème c'est que ces
convictions elles sont variante est
changeante
le jour où on pourra rouvrir les lieux
je vous cite ils doivent être ouverts
pour tous
je ne considère pas que l'on puisse dire
un français que s'il est vacciné il peut
aller au restaurant et que s'il n'est
pas vacciné il ne puisse pas y
il est tout à l'heure dans mon amant
dans mon amendement et vous n'étiez pas
là j'ai dit que pour mettre en place un
pass aujourd'hui j'ai et je ne suis pas
hostile à ce à se passe bien au
contraire
comme je souhaite que la vaccination le
plus vite possible
je soulignais simplement qu'il faut
donner les moyens à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent de pouvoir être vaccinés dans
les meilleurs délais je n'ai pas dit
qu'il faudra mettre le passe quand tout
le monde sera vacciné simplement quand
on a tous les moyens d'être vaccinées ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui des
français qui souhaitent peuvent être
vaccinées doivent attendre plusieurs
semaines
aujourd'hui les délais de rendez-vous et
les doses manque
vous l'avez dit hier en réponse à
valérie rabault vous n'êtes pas clair
sur les chiffres aujourd'hui il manque
des doses et comme il manque aujourd'hui
de la volonté pour accélérer cette
campagne
nous avons trois mois de retard par
rapport à la grande-bretagne les
etats-unis et israël et vous venez nous
donner des leçons
un peu d'humilité monsieur mais voilà
mes chers collègues je vous indiquais
qu'il y avait des scrutins publics donc
chacun je considère n'aura pas à chaque
fois faire cette rue en transhumance
chacun regagne sa place à l'est le 141
est identique demande de suite un public
de liberté territoire et des
républicains avis défavorable de
monsieur le ministre et de monsieur le
rapporteur
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos votants 220 exprimé 219 pour 92
contre 127 c'est rejeter sur l'autre
série d'amendements 148 demande de
certains publics exprimées par les
républicains le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat votants 218 exprimé 217 pour 92
contre 125
l'amendement est rejeté le 363 monsieur
rufin
le problème numéro un dans cette crise
zelko vide c'est la démocratie c'est la
démocratie qui est passé par dessus bord
quand on lit lundi dernier dans la
presse
un conseiller du président juste avant
l'intervention qui dit bon faire le parc
sanitaire ça me paraît très compliqué
mais le président peut nous surprendre
et en effet en dix minutes à la télé on
a la surprise parce sanitaire
obligatoire c'est-à-dire là notre devoir
c'est de poser des limites à la toute
puissance d'un pouvoir et on doit
chercher c'est ce que fait la droite
avec les amendements en disant voilà on
doit se revoir on fait ça en disant
voilà ça devient d'ailleurs du débat à
l'assemblée nationale
mais là je poste que avant que le
président annonce des décisions comme ça
à la télévision un certain nombre
d'instances doivent être consultés dont
la défenseur des droits la défenseure
des droits qui vient de rendre un avis
où elle dit regretter l'absence d'un
débat démocratique alors que depuis
décembre 2020 elle réclame
l'organisation d'un débat démocratique
public de fonds en dix ans le choix
d'une procédure accélérée compte tenu de
l'ampleur des atteintes aux droits et
libertés fondamentales prévues par ce
projet de loi ainsi que du caractère
inédit du certaines dispositions qu'ils
comportent
c'est à dire que dans la moiteur de
l'été en une nuit comme ça à la va vite
on a très clairement le basculement dans
une société où chacun va devenir la
police de tout le monde elle le dit
d'ailleurs elle dit la défenseur des
droits elle s'interroge sur le choix des
deux troyens des entreprises privées une
forme de pouvoir de police assurant elle
même les contrôles de la détention n'a
pas salutaire pour les personnes
souhaitant accéder à leurs services
ce contrôle devrait relever des
autorités publiques compte tenu des
risques inhérents à l'exercice du
pouvoir
elle parle des discriminations à
l'emploi elle évoque aussi les atteintes
aux droits de l'enfant qu'ils paraissent
grave
tout comme le compte du conseil
consultatif national de l'équipe tic et
il me semble que ces instants cela avant
que le décision le président n'a danse
des décisions mais deux
être consultés merci monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président c'est un
avis défavorable le présent article
organise déjà des consultations pire
qu'il n'entre que ce soit le conseil
scientifique et la cnil notamment l'avis
de monsieur le ministre
alors j'ai deux demandes de parole de
demandes de parole monsieur jumelles et
me sers mieux on a on a un ministre qui
nous dit droit dans ses bottes
si j'avais pu j'aurais généraliser le
pass sanitaires sont revenir devant vous
et si j'avais pu je continuerai à
décider tout seul sur le parlement
contre le parlement l'ensemble des
mesures qui sont extraordinairement
efficace
tellement que vous êtes obligé de
revenir dessus à chaque fois que un
nouvel événement sanitaires se déroule
c'est là-bas enfin comment ça on a on a
un ministre et qui considèrent que la
démocratie que le temps du débat et du
temps de perdu
nous considérons nous que la démocratie
le temps du débat contradictoire
peut-être aussi un gain d'efficacité
d'efficience pour apporter une réponse
collective à la crise sans précédent à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés et
peut-être même de renforcer l'adhésion
de la communauté nationale qui chaque
jour un peu plus et exprime des réserves
profonde à l'égard de l'autoritarisme
dont vous faites preuve c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'amendement de notre
collègue rufin qui vise à encadrer les
atteintes portées aux libertés
individuelles fondamentales la mérite
d'être étudiée méritent d'être examinées
et le fait de prendre l'avis de la
défenseure des droits du conseil
national d'éthique n'est pas du temps de
perdu mais est aussi un gage que pendant
cette crise les principes fondamentaux
de liberté auquel la présidente de la
commission des lois a réaffirmé son
attachement il ya encore quelques
semaines soit garanti jusqu'au bout de
la gestion de cette crise sanitaire
voilà pourquoi nous voterons cet
amendement fermiers
président monsieur le ministre pour que
le pass sanitaire soit efficace il faut
que la vaccination soit accessible à
tout le monde
or dans mon département le jura cet
après midi j'ai quelques médecins qui
m'ont appelé pour me dire qu'il y avait
plus de possibilités de primo
vaccination c'est à dire le deun dans ce
département
pendant plusieurs semaines que la rs de
bourgogne franche comté a précisé qu'il
ne pouvait plus y avoir de vaccination
dans un certain nombre de départements
de bourgogne et franche-comté je pense
notamment au département du doubs et au
département du jura en d1 pendant
plusieurs semaines ça veut donc dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous manquons de vaccins
les vaccinodromes sont bien là les
professionnels de santé ont repoussé
leurs congés ou même supprimer leurs
congés pour pouvoir être présent ce qui
lui manque en fait c'est ce que l'état
devrait nous donner c'est à dire les
vaccins monsieur le ministre vous avez
un double discours alors exprimez-vous
clairement sur la capacité de fournir
les vaccins sur l'ensemble de la france
et pour l'ensemble des français
merci monsieur servir je vais m monsieur
le ministre bien sûr vous souhaitiez la
parole
j'étais en train de me connecter sur
d'octo libre pour regarder combien de
rendez vous était disponible de
vaccination monsieur le député vous avez
vous avez fait allusion un message je
vous cherche je ne trouve plus ses vous
êtes la leaf allusion au message du
directeur général de l'ars bourgogne
franche comté qui l'avait envoyé à des
préfets pour leur signifier que étant
donné la très forte demande
il voulait commencer à ce qu'on dirait
lycée les primo vaccination sur les huit
prochaines semaines si vous êtes pardon
députés vous avez l'air informé sur
votre département de votre territoire
vous ne pouvez pas ignorer que quelques
heures plus tard le même directeur
envoyez un courrier expliquant qu'en
réalité il y avait quarante mille doses
supplémentaires qui était arrivé sur la
région qui évidemment les premières
injections allait augmenter et que nous
allions ouvrir en bourgogne franche
comté dans le jura comme partout en
france
de très nombreux créneaux de primo
vaccination dans les prochains jours
comme dans le reste du pays
monsieur le député compte pas pour ne
rien vous cacher
nous travaillons avec les centres pour
qu'ils puissent ouvrir massivement des
créneaux dans les dix prochains jours de
manière même à rapprocher les
rendez-vous qui ont été pris en août
d'ici à la fin du mois de juillet vous
avez 60
vous avez 70 % des personnes adultes à
ce stade en france qui ont eu une
première injection 70% ce n'est pas
complètement neutre c'est en train de
monter très vite nous atteindrons très
vite 75 puis 80%
d'ailleurs nous sommes nous allons
rejoindre la symptômes qu'on voit dans
les enquêtes d'opinion sur les
intentions des français de se faire
vacciner
encore une fois on va on peut on peut
passer la nuit on peut même si vous
voulez passer la semaine à se renvoyer
la balle vous qui nous dit
dites-nous vous peuvent accéder tout le
monde vous dira oui pour le pass à
lithaire nous qui vous disons c'est pas
l'un ou l'autre c'est l'un et l'autre
nous mettons à disposition des vaccins
nous allons maxime vacciner massivement
nous
sinon mobiliser tous les efforts huit
cent vingt mille vaccination encore
aujourd'hui notre pays n'ont plus de
quatre cent mille français qui
recevaient leur première injection
il en ira ainsi les mêmes crescendo dans
les prochains jours donc ça c'est en
cours de fonctionnement
il n'empêche il n'empêche qu'il y ait un
virus que le virus il nous regarde et je
pense que ce soir il serait assez
content et servir une petite bière
parce qu'il va lui dit non parce que
honnêtement nous avons besoin d'avoir
des mesures de protection des français
et des établissements recevant du public
et corbier je leur dis et je le martèle
raid toute la soirée et toute la nuit
par monsieur petit monsieur ciotti vous
avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que l'échangé d'avis vous
avez vous allez madame monsieur pradier
la question fut radié nom seul mais
fulmine y sera pas arrêté je crois que
le temps je suis de cette parole à tous
les orateurs de tous les goûts qu'ils
ont en tout cas ceux qui l'ont demandé
on écoute le ministre la question
monsieur ce qui n'est pas l'avis n'est
pas de savoir si j'ai changé d'avis la
question est de savoir si mes
convictions sont intègres
elles le sont je n'aime pas l'outil
passe sanitaires je ne je n'aime pas une
société dans laquelle nous sommes
contraints à demander à pass à lithaire
la question elle est de la décision et
de la nécessité les seuls députés
gouverner c'est choisir et parfois faire
des choix qui ne nous plaisent pas et
c'est ça le courage en politique le
député c'est pas de faire durer les
débats en nous disant c'est à cause de
nous qu'il y aurait de l'obstruction
parlementaire
gouverner c'est choisir c'est faire des
choix qui ne nous plaisent pas pour
protéger les autres ils de la même
manière quand nous appelons les français
la responsabilité et celles et ceux qui
hésitent à se faire vacciner et curé
qu'on leur dit faites vous vacciner
ça ne vous plaît peut-être pas mais
c'est important pour vous et les autres
c'est le courage que nous demandons
français et c'est le courage que je
demande à la représentation nationale de
nous accompagner
non pas dans nos convictions mais dans
les choix nécessaires pour protéger les
français
entre deux solutions mauvaises le
confinement et le passe je choisis le
pass regardant quel sera votre choix
minutes
alors sur cet amendement le 300 forme 3
nous avons recueilli un avis négatif
défavorable de monsieur le ministre et
de monsieur le rapporteur
je le mets en voit qui est pour et qui
est contre
il est rejeté le 66 n'est pas défendu
monsieur fige le 539
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
présente amendement vise à insérer une
exception à l'obligation de présentation
du pass sanitaires à savoir les contre
indications médicales
certaines personnes notamment en raison
de leur état de santé ne peuvent se
faire vacciner ne peuvent pas non plus
subir un test virologique du fait de la
prise d'anticoagulants ou du fait de
souffrir d'hémophilie par exemple le
présent projet de loi
si on médical s'agissant de la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants il
est proposé au travers de sa
d'amendements de prévoir ce même cas de
figure pour le pas de sanitaires je vous
remercie
merci monsieur chiche monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président le
gouvernement a pris des engagements
fermes hier en commission
et cette question un temps tentures de
traiter par le décret prévu alinéa 32
donc avis défavorable sur cet amendement
monsieur le ministre madame genevard
madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais revenir sur cette
affaire de la bourgogne franche comté
pardonnez moi mais je voulais intervenir
lors de la défense du précédente
amendement parce que cette affaire est
quand même singulièrement grave
avant-hier tous les centres de
vaccination du département du doubs ont
reçu un message de la rs de bourgogne
franche comté 10 ans suite à un accident
majeur au niveau national concernant les
dotations de vaccins dont qu'il
s'agissait bien du nombre de doses
disponibles ne plus prendre de rendez
vous d un tous les rendez-vous des 1 qui
reste disponible à cette heure doivent
être fermées pour ces vous sont
définitivement fermées tous les centres
de vaccination ont reçu ce message suivi
d'une réunion avec la rs en disant nous
ne pourrons plus primo vacciner sans
doute jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août
évidemment tollé général parce que c'est
complètement en contradiction avec
l'incitation à la vaccination qui doit
permettre de recouvrer de la liberté
mais le plus fort c'est que aujourd'hui
le préfet du doubs informe les mêmes que
non il n'y a pas de problème tous les
rendez-vous vont pouvoir être honorées
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ce bazar
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bazar
monsieur le ministre il faut vous ne
répondiez précisément qu'est ce qui
s'est passé madame la présidente
monsieur coquerel oui et monsieur
cochrane
voilà je voulais vous avez vu qu'on va
demander la parole immédiatement je veux
il était en mal que je vous la donne
vous étiez le seul orateur à la demande
ainsi mais je vous vois plus reprises
interrompre les orateurs et utah on va
de respect de dialogue mais au niveau du
bon ton vous devriez le dire au ministre
au cycle a évoqué tout le monde
attendait pour voir ici mais si mais si
les si messi enfin c'était pas la
question je voulais poser en
l'occurrence
donc il ya le problème qui est soulevée
par cet amendement est important je
crois que comme tous les collègues on
reçoit effectivement beaucoup de
personnes qui ne peuvent pas pour des
raisons médicales se faire vacciner qui
souhaiteraient être éclairé sur ce qui
va se passer
il ya une réponse du rapporteur qui ne
tente pas très précises voilà mais je
voudrais en profiter pour poser une
autre question au ministre les gens qui
ont été contaminées avant le le 28 mars
ont été normalement enregistrées sur un
système d'information nous dit-on qui
s'appelle le cidep apparemment vous
service son cours or ceux-ci depp a
écrasé toutes les données ce qui fait
que les gens qui ont été contaminés et
qui veulent le faire savoir pour comme
vous le savez n'avoir droit qu'à une
une dose de vaccin aujourd'hui sont dans
cette incapacité de le faire de ce fait
la part amundi que vos services sont
courants je voulais savoir qu'est ce qui
peut être fait à ce sujet 6 merci
monsieur les plus qu'à monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député corbières
monsieur cordière monsieur coquerel
pardon quand ça n'a jamais quand c'était
dans cet hémicycle il ya quelques mois
je sais pas si c'était vous mes enfants
y avait sur de plusieurs bornes
d'opposition jeu je vous ai demandé de
ne pas adopter un amendement qui nous
contraignait à écraser toutes les
données de sidney govou de trois mois et
je me souviens vous avoir dit ici que
les données de 6 des ponts n'aurait
besoin de les conserver pour conserver
tant que l'épidémie n'était pas terminée
le statut sérologique des personnes qui
avaient été infectés vous avez vous nous
avez battu mesdames et messieurs les
députés et nous avons suivi la loi nous
avons écrasé les données cidep moi ce
que je vous propose c'est de déposer un
amendement pour revenir sur ce que vous
avez voté la dernière fois nous habitons
effectivement de faire perdre du temps
précieux aux français et des données de
santé voire pourquoi pas de faire
confiance aux autorités de santé que
parfois nous relayons dans cet hémicycle
merci monsieur le ministre alors je vais
mettre aux voix l'amendement et ensuite
je vous demanderais bon vous le voulez
maintenant d'accord wells il ya un
rappel au règlement de monsieur chiche
monsieur chiche mais c'est chiche
boussou ya un rappel au règlement de mai
que chedjou qui va nous dire sur quelle
l'arctique ont et merci monsieur le
président sur l'article sans alinéa 7
par rapport aux avis et absence de
réponses qui ont été apportées sur mon
amendement
je ne comprends pas votre réponse est
votre avis monsieur le rapporteur qui
fait allusion
un décret qui viendraient qui règlerait
la solution donc législateur et
parlementaire je crois qu'on règle les
choses par la loi singulièrement quand
on parle de personnes qui seraient
prêtes à obtenir un pass sanitaire mais
qu'ils ont raison leur santé ne le
peuvent pas et monsieur le ministre je
me permets de vous demander également
votre avis parce que là il a été limpide
il est absolument inexistante
merci monsieur le président oui j'ai été
extrêmement généreux parce que la ligne
chiche
on va voter sur votre amendement un avis
défavorable
il est rejeté
mais deux orateurs ça vaut pour tout le
monde le 375 lesieu ménagers et si vous
l'acceptez monsieur débuté le 3 178
également oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
tout à l'heure qu'il y avait urgence ce
qui est bien la démonstration du défaut
d'anticipation de votre politique qu'on
ne cesse de dénoncer et qui
malheureusement la marque de fabrique
vous faites des déclarations à
l'emporte-pièce contredite quelques
jours parfois quelques heures après par
d'autres déclarations à l'emporte-pièce
c'est bien ce qui sape le moral de nos
concitoyens et qui malheureusement mais
à bas la confiance que les françaises et
les français peuvent avoir dans leur
politique
alors il ya quelques semaines seulement
alors même que les variants existaient
déjà et même le delta nous avons tous
entendu le président de la république
nous dira qu' on était à quelques heures
de retrouver les jours heureux
tu parles néanmoins message reçu par
cinq sur cinq par les français par les
entreprises par les associations qui ont
programmé de nombreuses manifestations
festivités et des vacances le pass
sanitaire est en réalité le triste
résultat de l'incapacité du gouvernement
à voir rapidement déployer la seule arme
que nous ayons à savoir le vaccin vous
nous avez fait perdre trois mois et
aujourd'hui c'est la liberté des
français qui errent en paye le prix fort
sans votre gestion hasardeuse du début
qui a été rattrapé d'ailleurs grâce à
l'intervention des collectivités
territoriales nous aurions les mêmes
chiffres de vaccination que les autres
pays qui ne sont pas obligés d'avoir
recours au pass sanitaires mon
amendement en réalité puisque vous
semblez tenir à ce passe sanitaires que
nous dénonçons et bien c'est tout
simplement au moins d'avoir la décence
de reporter les délais de son
application car on est à cela n'est
juste pas possible
mais si monsieur le rapporteur font ces
deux amendements
merci monsieur le président le régime du
passeport sanitaires et un distingue du
pass sanitaire est en vigueur depuis le
2 juin 2021 et ce même ses prémisses
remonte à la loi du 9 juillet 2020 donc
un avis défavorable pour les deux
amendements
non madame k - madame firmin le bodo
oui merci monsieur le président pour
adobe pour les personnes qui
je pense de rectifier cette
problématique
merci même la députée mais ce que
bouffier chat ou que j'ai dû mal
entendre
chers collègues m danger la situation
sanitaire n'était pas du tout la même
urgence sanitaire oui elle était de
nature à nous permettre de retourner et
de dire que nous retournions à la vie
normale dans une période où l'épidémie
était en train de reculer à très grande
vitesse et où nous étions en dessous des
5000 cas de contamination par jour la
réalité est qu'en france c'est dans
l'ensemble des pays actuellement et
chacun essaye de s'adapter avec urgence
et s'est depuis quelques jours qu
effectivement nous avons un doublement
des cas de contamination comme dans les
autres états l'italie elle même
actuellement est en train de se poser la
question par exemple sur le pass
sanitaire de l'étendre aux grands
événements culturels mais aussi aux
événements à la vie du quotidien
c'est cette réalité là à laquelle nous
devons faire face et apporter des
réponses dans l'urgence oui pour
protéger nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens pour freiner l'épidémie sans
fermer les activités économiques
toujours merci et de votre merci
monsieur le député je vais mettre voit
le 375 avis défavorable de monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté 378 même avis qu'est pour
qui et contre rejeté nous pas fin à une
discussion commune d'abord des identique
sur lesquels le 269 monsieur il ya ou il
y à une demande des républicains et
demandes de scrutins publics des
républicains sur votre amendement il est
identique monsieur le député vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente
cet amendement vise à préciser que les
mesures du présent article ne concerne
pas que les adultes mais également les
jeunes des adolescents à partir de 12
ans et c'était un amendement de
cohérence avec la suite du texte je vous
remercie
merci monsieur bazin ou monsieur
gosselin le 4 5 1 je prends même temps
le 413 ainsi sont liés proches
en signe de bonne volonté oui il faut
faire la distinction entre les
majeures et les mineurs de moins de 12
ans qui eux ne peuvent pas être vaccinés
je crois qu'il faut préciser les choses
c'est pas la peine de compliquer la vie
des familles c'est déjà assez simple en
ce moment sans qu'on en rajoute
voilà l'objet de ces deux amendements je
fais bref et rapide merci monsieur le
député monsieur le rapporteur
à l'initiative de monsieur bouficha en
commission sur le pass annie terre c'est
un avis favorable à cette précision
apportée par les amendements 269 et 415
conforme à l'état du droit et dans le
cadre du passeport sanitaires par contre
défavorable sur le 413 puisqu'il s'agit
d'un dispositif européen peut être
appliquée de manière équivalente partout
en europe pour être efficace merci
monsieur ministre a vite sagesse sur les
269 ce que m l'âge de 12 ans dans la loi
me semble pas ne semble pas hip
sur les 4
40-15 et 413 oui merci monsieur le
président je profite de cet amendement
pour réagir suite à l'audition de la
présidente de l'aqrp
pour le débat parlementaire et je fait
état ici d'un de ses points puisqu'elle
invite le parlement à s'interroger de
façon précise sur les lieux où le pass
sanitaire savent elles réellement
s'avère réellement nécessaire et sur la
possibilité de ne pas inclure les
mineurs dans le dispositif donc je
voudrais connaître votre sentiment par
rapport aux déclarations de la
présidente
c'est un très court rappel au règlement
au titre de l'article sentir et 7 pour
faire juste remarqué à monsieur le
ministre il a donné un avis de sagesse
sur le 400 sur les 269 de chez elia oui
et un avis défavorable sur 415 alors que
les deux amendements sont strictement
identiques yeux jumelles mais on a eu
deux
je vous aurais a pas de débat sur la
manière dont vous envisagiez de
mobiliser la médecine scolaire dès la
rentrée et donc de mobiliser des moyens
dès maintenant pour que la médecine
scolaire sera opérationnel à la rentrée
afin d'emporter la conviction des jeunes
et des familles sur l'enjeu de la
vaccination jeu j'aimerais avoir une
réponse sur la manière dont vous
envisagez de réarmer de réparer de
préparer la médecine scolaire de ce
deuxième élément je veux vous poser une
question et qui n'est pas polémique
un enfant dont les parents pour des
raisons idéologiques sont réticents à la
vaccination et qui se trouve donc en
situation de ne pas être vaccinés que se
passe-t-il pour lui à la rentrée lorsque
sur les séjours éducatifs sur les
sorties périscolaires sur la découverte
du cinéma des lieux de culture de tout
ce qui est constitutif à l'éveil de nos
enfants que se passe-t-il pour cet
enfant qui n'aura pas d'autre choix que
de suivre
l'autorité parentale acteurs dont ça
dans son intégration dans l'école
j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous
répondre parce que c'est supposé aux
mômes évidemment au maire accessoirement
au maire y compris des communes sur en
charge de l'activité périscolaire donc
comment envisagez vous
de continuer à faire la promotion de
l'état qui protège tous et partout en
ayant une mesure qui risque discriminer
des enfants qui n'auront pas eu le choix
que d'assumer cette situation qu'il faut
merci monsieur le député alors je mets
aux voix le 269 sur lequel il ya un avis
de sa geste monsieur le ministre est un
avis défavorable sagesse également
favorable pas non alors je répète sur le
269 avis favorable de monsieur le
rapporteur et sagesse de monsieur le
ministre un scrutin public un demande
des républicains allaient le scrutin est
ouvert
il est clos votants 244 exprimé 208 pour
181 contre 28 il est adopté
[Applaudissements]
wii le wii wheel de 423 tombe nous en
venons pas non nous devons voter sur le
avant monsieur gosselin défendu monsieur
merci monsieur le rapporteur
donc c'est un moment on avait pour effet
de rendre inapplicable dispositif du
passeport sanitaires aux personnes
voyageant avec masques qui pourrait
ainsi se rendre sans vérifier qu'ils
sont contagieux dans des territoires
particulièrement vulnérables face à
l'épidémie donc c'est un avis
défavorable je le mets aux voix qui est
pour et contre
il est rejetée le 9 69
même la députée merci
pind à thouars est particulièrement
présent dans le domaine de l'emploi dans
lequel les mesures prévues par le projet
de loi ont pour conséquence d'opérer in
fine et une distinction entre les
travailleurs détenteur de l'un des trois
documents demandés et les autres et ce
qui se perd là par petites tranches
c'est en effet de la discrimination à
l'emploi et rendre la vie impossible des
gens qui refusent cet acte merci
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur président donc il s'agit
d'une mesure de cohérence et pertinente
d'un point de vue sanitaire donc ce sera
un avis défavorable ses ministres je
mets aux voix le 11/09 qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejetée le 9 cents
merci monsieur président donc il s'agit
d'une mesure de cohérence et pertinente
d'un point de vue sanitaire donc ce sera
un avis défavorable ses ministres je
mets aux voix le 11/09 qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejetée le 9 cents
neuf de ses disciples du filet pour
n'est pas défendu discussion commune le
d'aborder l'identique le 85 monsieur
pause
oui merci monsieur le président sur le
ministre cet amendement vous propose
d'élargir la validité du passani terre
aux premières doses c'est à dire aux
primo vacciner parce qu'il développe
déjà une immunité qui est important
qu'ils sont moins contaminant et ils
sont surtout dans une démarche positive
vis-à-vis de la vaccination ça c'est
vraiment un signal fort pour encourager
la vaccination et il me semble ça serait
aussi une mesure juste et cohérente par
rapport aux annonces se précipiter non
concertée et non anticipé du président
de la république il ya quelques jours
merci monsieur projet pendant que madame
l'ovj s'exprime si la bad va voir un
petit peu ses collègues parce que là
j'ai trop de demandes de la part de
parole du même du même groupe le 212
madame nouvelle juge oui merci monsieur
le président cet amendement est de
nature à faciliter la mise en oeuvre de
l'expansion du pass sanitaire jeu ici en
préalable rappelé qu'un certain nombre
de personnes qui sont opposés au passage
iter ne sont pas opposés à la
vaccination ou dit autrement certain
nombre de personnes qui sont vaccinées
au favorable à la vaccination sont
défavorables au pass sanitaires
l'extension du pass sanitaire
aujourd'hui est fait dans la
précipitation ce qui conduit à des
difficultés pour un certain nombre de
personnes pour prendre des rendez-vous
cela a été rappelé avec toutes les
difficultés que cas notamment évoqué
notre collègue annie genevard il ya
quelques instants sur certains
territoires par rapport à cette
difficulté pour pouvoir se faire
vacciner
il est important de faciliter la mise en
oeuvre est ce qui vous est proposé au
travers cet amendement c'est d'accorder
le pass sanitaires aux primo vacciner
étant entendu que nous savons que la
première injection donne déjà une
certaine immunité
je pense que par rapport à cette période
estivale qui fortement attendu par un
grand nombre de nos concitoyens
ce dispositif aujourd'hui va conduire
probablement à gâcher la période
estivale de certains français donc cet
amendement vise à favoriser faire en
sorte que cette période estivale soit
moins moins gâchée pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux
merci même le vj le 268 n'est pas
défendu me suis ménagé le 380 ha oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la vaccination pour pour tous
et notamment pour les mineurs n'est
ouverte que depuis huit semaines
ça veut dire que quand on sait que le
parcours vaccinale prend de six à dix
semaines 12 semaines en fonction de du
délai entre les deux doses puis le délai
pour que le pass and i care soit en
vigueur nous vous proposons de prendre
en considération dans le calendrier de
cette loi est le temps nécessaire pour
celles et ceux qui auront déjà une
première dose de vaccin et qui devrait
de ce fait pouvoir avoir accès aux
établissements publics au service avec
la présentation de cette première dose
merci même avec vous l'avez pas vu ou
donne la parole
le 268 défendu le cap 117 députés peru
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
ministre
nos concitoyens ont besoin de
considération et de confiance dans votre
part et un certain nombre ont décidé
bien évidemment d'aller se faire
vacciner mais vous ne prenez pas en
compte ce temps nécessaire pour pouvoir
accomplir le parcours de vaccination au
complet les primo vacciner développement
déjà une immunité importante ou le sait
tous étant beaucoup moins contaminant il
convient d'élargir la validité du passé
ni terre à ces personnes afin qu'elles
puissent accéder aux lieux aux
établissements dans les mêmes conditions
bien sûr que les autres la réalisation
d'une première dose de vaccin témoignent
de leur part d'une entrée dans le site
de vaccination qui mérite donc le
respect
conformément à l'esprit aux objectifs du
dispositif de passes sanitaire étendue
inscrits dans ce projet de loi et je
crois que ce serait dans votre part
monsieur le ministre un geste fort en
direction de tous seuls et tous ceux
justement qui décide d'aller se faire
vacciner
suite à l'appel du président de la
république merci le 590 n'est pas
défendu le 731 monsieur des coeurs
brisés justin monde
le président pour rappeler ici il est
important de prendre la situation
particulière de cette personne qui ont
entamé un parcours vaccinale mais
n'aurait pas n'aurait reçu qu'une
première injection
tout simplement parce qu'elles n'ont pas
la maîtrise du calendrier des
vaccinations des dates qui leur sont
proposés ou comme ça a été rappelé par
nos collègues parce que les quantités de
vaccins disponibles ne leur permettent
pas de remplir ce parcours dans des
délais impartis je crois qu'il est
important d'en tenir compte
merci le 1080 trail ne me semble pas
défendu monsieur le rapporteur attendant
n'ont donc il se désole mais fut
rapporteur ya une discussion commune
madame genevard le 953 merci monsieur le
président madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre
cet amendement comme l'on dit mes
collègues propose de reconnaître à sa
juste mesure
l'entrée dans le parcours vaccinale en
reconnaissant l'importance d'une d'une
primo vaccination d'autant que ce
parcours vaccinale est parfois un
parcours fort difficile je reviens à
l'histoire de la bourgogne franche comté
le 19 le 19 la rs de bourgogne franche
comté dit c'est fini
plus d'accès nations plus de primo
vaccination on interrompt tout il donne
des chiffres on a demandé 200 mille
doses supplémentaires on en a que 40000
disponibles donc on arrête tout on gèle
le parcours vaccinale le 20 et le 21 le
préfet dit voyant que la sphère faisait
quand même grand bruit
le préfet rétabli la possibilité d'une
primo vaccination très bien par quel
truchement on n'en sait rien sauf que
aujourd'hui même nous avons des
témoignages d'habitants du doubs qui ont
souhaité se faire vacciner et qui n'ont
pas pu faute de doses disponibles
aujourd'hui même donc vous voyez bien
qu'il ya quand même un vrai sujet alors
pour ceux qui ont réussi
mais enfin madame la présidente de la
commission
vous faites des gestes comme si je
disais quelque chose d'aberrant c'est
pas moi c'est la mairesse la rs
documents officiels n'ont aujourd'hui
dans le doubs des gens veulent se faire
primo vacciner ils ne le peuvent pas
comment cela est-il possible
alors pour ceux qui ont réussi à entrer
dans le parcours vaccinale nous
proposons qu'il soit reconnu et
intégrées comme ceux qui ont achevé leur
parcours vaccinale mais si monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur pays n'ont donc ce sera
un avis défavorable pour eux ces
amendements pour deux raisons d'abord
nous sommes dans le cadre contraignant
du passeport sanitaires européens dont
les modalités de mise en oeuvre sont
déterminés au niveau communautaire et le
deuxième seul le schéma maximale complet
protège de manière satisfaisante
merci monsieur le ministre
attendez laissez voilà d'abord je vais
répondre à nouveau sur la question de la
rs bon ben franche-comté genevard et je
pense qu'on pourra peut-être clôturer le
sujet j'ai dit tout à l'heure madame là
bas si vous laissez moi une chance de
vous convaincre
merci d'un député j'ai dit stoner que
lorsque directeur général de la rs
envoyer un e-mail malheureux malheureux
à des préfets nous l'avons contacté il
s'est rendu compte en travaillant avec
la ta science vaccinale que les termes
qu'il avait employée n'était pas perçue
comme il le souhaitait et madame la
députée
oui vous êtes et vous êtes lectrice de
l'est républicain madame la députée bien
dans l'est républicain
alors si vous l'avez lu lisez le à
l'assemblée parce que le directeur
général de la grèce a dit ceci les des
incendies avaient primo injection ne
sont pas suspendus
il a été simplement rappelé ce matin
qu'elle devait s'inscrire dans le cadre
strict des quotas alloués l'élan vers la
vaccination observée depuis les annonces
présidentielles
en fait ça vous embête que j'ai répondu
à vos questions plus je réponds à vos
questions factuellement plus vous parler
fort pour découvrir si c'est pas
d'obstruction
j'aurais essayé de vous répondre vous
n'avez lester république et à vous
trouverez la réponse
par ailleurs c'est pas d'obstruction
quand on pose 10 fois un amendement et
qu'on le défende 10 x 2 minutes vous
aimez sur les députés bien sûr que si
nous si vous souhaitez que le débat
avance
j'entendais la première intervention du
député l'est républicain disait que le
prénom la république avait décidé de la
vaccination obligatoire du pass à lutter
sans aucune concertation
pardon vous avez été concertée par le
premier ministre plusieurs jours avant
l'intervention du président vous avez
même répondu plusieurs jours avant
l'intervention du président est votre
président du groupe que je salue pour
son ouverture d'esprit à lui-même
communiqué plusieurs jours avant
l'intervention du président pour dire
qu'il y était favorable
donc ne dit pas qui est pas de
concertation et ne dit pas vous ne
faites pas d'obstruction c'est factuel
sur la question c'est compliqué de
l'assumer mais c'est comme ça sur la
question de voeux le fond votre
amendement sur le fond votre amant dans
la primovaccination quand on n'a reçu
qu'une dose
quand on n'a reçu qu'une dose de vaccin
on a un degré d'immunité d'environ 30%
ça fait une réduction du risque
d'infection enfin 30% de réduction du
risque ce n'est pas une réduction
suffisante
on est très loin des 80 90 % de
réduction liée au double vaccination
vous vous dites il faut encourager les
gens qui ont déjà fait une première
injection et leur donner accès aux pas
salutaire moi je vous dis si on donne le
pasa littera des gens qui n'ont eu
qu'une injection ya plus de passes annie
terre parce que vous avez quand même 70%
de risques que si les gens étaient
exposés il est attrapé le virus puisque
n'avait que 30 % de protection conférée
par une seule dose ça veut dire vous
allez voir des gens sans masque à
l'intérieur qui vont côtoyer qui sont
protégés mais qui vont côtoyer des gens
qui de son quart à degrés un film de
protection
donc ça non je vous le demande ne pas le
voter ça c'est dangereux
par contre ce qui peut être à ce stade
sauf si les scientifiques
l inverse mais aujourd'hui ils me disent
non par contre qu'on pourrait envisager
mais c'est pas dans le cas de cet
amendement là pour encourager je dirais
la primovaccination ce serait peut-être
de reconnaître et sa ged sollicité les
autorités sanitaires et scientifiques
parce que c'est pas moi dans mon bureau
ni jeu pendant cette émission qu'on a la
connaissance et les données pour pouvoir
le décider j'ai sollicité les autorités
scientifiques pour voir s'il était
possible de reconnaître la validité d'un
test antigénique ou pcr qui serait
réalisé toutes les semaines et non tous
les deux jours pour les gens qui
auraient déjà reçu une dose il y aurait
un côté incitatif y aurait un côté
réduction du risque
je n'ai pas encore la réponse et parce
que j'ai cette rigueur je suis désolé et
c'est important dans la gestion d'une
crise sanitaire
je vous demande que nous attendions
d'avoir la réponse des autorités
sanitaires avant de nous prononcer sur
cette question
donc je vous propose de retrait cet
amendement ou un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre alors j'ai
deux demandes de parole je crois savoir
que pour les républicains disent qu'ils
avaient plusieurs sims d'or a élu
monsieur d'or merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
une primo infection une primo injection
de vaccin faille there vous connaissez
et j'en suis sûr les résultats des
études israéliennes qui ont confirmé une
immunité de 90% pendant trois semaines
c'est à dire qu'une prime une injection
immunise pendant trois semaines 6 alors
là je vous donne les études israélienne
et également celle du laboratoire trois
semaines d'immunité donc nous avons une
descente de l'immunité après trois
semaines ce qui fait que pendant ces
trois semaines s'ils ont été vaccinées
dans la première injection en juillet
dès l'instant où les le pr le présent la
république a annoncé qu'il fallait se
faire vacciner les jeunes ont foncé dans
le sas est un problème que l'on voit sur
le terrain
dans mon centre j'ai vu les jeunes
arrivés tout de suite après ils vont
être immunisés jusqu'à fin août
grosso modo avant d'avoir la deuxième
injection dès l'instant où les doses
arrive en flux tendu parce que la même
chose qu'en région bourgogne
la région centre val de loire travaille
en flux tendu c'est à dire que nous soit
nous favorisons la première soit nous
favorisons la deuxième dose donc nous
avons des sujets importants
si on veut que les jeunes puissent
sortir puisse être avoir un passé ni
terre pendant le mois de juillet août et
bien il faut voter ces amendements
merci monsieur vigier oui merci ce
président ce ministre d'ailleurs dans la
poursuite du débat hier en commission
vous avez été ouverts en disant qu'on
pouvait ouvrir un passé à lesterps
provisoire je pense c'est vraiment une
bonne formule pour quoi et vous le savez
vous même si les gens ont pris cette
volonté d'aller se faire vacciner de
recevoir leur permis
la première 2 c'est à dire que quelque
part dès que vous sortez la première
dose le rendez vous les programmes et
pour la seconde et ça veut dire que on
part avec un certificat de vaccination
et celui ci devient caduque si jamais
naturellement la seconde vaccination n'a
pas lieu
non je crois que ç'a permis à la fois
d'avoir un pass sanitaire efficace et
deuxièmement de confirmer le fait qu'
évidemment vous le savez mieux que tous
aient la vaccination les seuls moyens
d'éradiquer cette pandémie
moi je suis à titre personnel très
favorable à une vaccination obligatoire
je trouve vraiment que celles et ceux
qui massivement depuis quelques semaines
on choisit sur faire vacciner puis
quatre millions et demi de français
depuis une dizaine de jours
et c'est vrai qu'il ya des tensions la
ministre brigitte bourguignon était pas
plus tard que lundi matin avant
territoire l'a pu constater en
catastrophe en a récupéré les doses
nécessaires mais franchement il ya des
tensions qui font que certains ne va
rentrer définitivement dans ce schéma
vaccinal en revanche après la première
vaccination si j'aime un petit
pourcentage qui différera tout petit peu
de jean-pierre d'heure il a que j'en
suis pas loin
franchement il ya une vraie immunité
pendant trois semaines prenons ces
chemins
c'est un bon chemin merci alors sur ces
amendements 85 est identique avis
défavorable de monsieur le ministre et
de monsieur le rapporteur je l'aimais
revoir qui est pour et qui est contre
ils font rejeter l'amendement de madame
la présidente jeanne var 1963 mais ma
vie qui est pour et qui est contre
rejetée nous en venons 1085 madame john
tg indique simplement que sur votre
amendement le groupe agir ensemble a
déposé une demande de ce qu est un
public il est annoncé dans l'hémicycle
l'enceinte de l'assemblée et que sur
l'amendement suivant le 780 le même
groupe a demandé également un scrutin
public et il est annoncé dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée management et merci
monsieur le président cet amendement
vise à propose d'introduire dans les
documents du pass sanitaire la sérologie
donc le taux d'anticorps à un niveau
qu'il faudra définir bien entendu ceci
permet de s'adresser de répondre à la
question de l'obtention d'un pass
sanitaires pour encore une fois les
personnes qui arrivent de l'étranger
notamment les français qui sont près de
3 millions et donc certains genres
d'abord souligner une chose ont pu avoir
accès à la vaccination grâce à
l'initiative du gouvernement français
qui pour un tout petit nombre d'entre
eux sur place nos français n'avaient pas
accès aucune vaccination et la
solidarité nationale a permis de les
protéger devrait le saluer et le et vous
en remercier une grande partie d'entre
eux pour autant la a eu accès à la
vaccination localement hélas cette fois
ci sur les demandes de nos ambassades
sur la demande de notre gouvernement et
parmi ces vaccinations certaines l'été
des vaccins non homologués ils ont pour
autant le on l'espère on le souhaite on
ne sait pas une protection qui peut donc
se mesurer par la sérologie et la
sérologie le mesure de leur taux
d'anticorps encore il faut avec un taux
minimum à définir avec un rythme à
définir car on sait que la sérologie
n'est pas forcément stable dans le temps
ça leur permettrait d'accéder à un pass
sanitaires plutôt que d'avoir recours à
la aux tests virologiques qui serait
fait tous les 48 heures c'est français
n'ont pas eu la possibilité de rentrer
en france depuis plus de deux ans ils
sont français comme tous les autres
cherchent à avoir accès à leurs passes
sanitaires comme tous les hauts de la
manière comme l'a demandé le président
de la république la plus simple et la
plus efficace la sérologie répond à cet
enjeu je vous remercie
la députée mais c'est le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame jeunes
étaient hier en commission j'ai été
sensible à votre argumentation sur le
fait que la question des français de
l'étranger devaient être prises à bras
le corps et que des solutions immédiates
et concrètes doivent être recherchées et
apportez donc j'émets un avis favorable
au dispositif que vous proposez maciel
min je suis désolé je vais être je vais
devoir casser l'ambiance même l'avis du
gouvernement sera très défavorable à cet
amendement pas un peu défavorable
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi si vous
me donnez deux minutes d'abord il ya une
saisine de la haute autorité de santé
sur cette question spécifique
la vie est récent l'entrée n'est pas
sèche la vie date du 23 juin 2021
la question était posée à la haute
autorité de santé le test sérologique
envisagée peut-il apporter une réponse à
deux cas pratique aujourd'hui
problématique pour les français de
l'étranger qui viennent en france et ne
peuvent utiliser leurs vaccins dans le
passé à lithaire parce qu'il n'est pas
reconnu en france ou pour les france et
d'étranger contaminée qui au bout de
trois mois ont un qr code défaillant on
est exactement dans le cas de figure
présenté par l'amendement de madame la
députée gendt et l'avis de la haute
autorité de santé en date du 23 juin
2021 exclut expressément l'utilisation
d'un test sérologique dans ces cas là je
les cite
il n'existe pas de données permettant de
définir des corrélats de protection
c'est à dire l'existence d'un niveau de
protection par rapport à un taux
d'anticorps mesurer les résultats des
tests sérologiques ne permettent pas de
statuer sur une protection conférée que
ce soit sur le niveau de protection ou
sur sa durée dans le temps sur sa durée
dans le temps
la nouvelle députée s'il y avait une
solution simple paresse s'il y avait une
solution simple par un seul dosage des
anticorps croyez-moi on serait pas
entrain par l'état sanitaire de
vaccination de monodoses de 2,2 double
dose et c'est cette solution et l'asthme
la sérologie
elle n'est pas utilisée dans les pays
madame la députée jeunes des cités hier
at her israël c'est faux je voulais dire
et vous vous avez pu le vérifier
c'est sérologie plus double vaccination
nous serions le seul pays dans toute la
coordination européenne a autorisé
dispositions qu'il est reconnu par
aucune instance scientifique au niveau
européen en revanche concernant le vrai
sujet le vrai sujet que qu'elle entrait
des français de l'étranger qui viennent
et qu'ils peuvent utiliser leur vaccin
donc pas salutaire parce qu'il n'est pas
reconnu
il ya deux cas qui doivent être
envisagées se vacciner par un vaccin
reconnu par le m à l' agence du
médicament européenne ou des équivalents
aux vaccins reconnu par le m&a dans ces
cas là c'est une difficulté qui
technique qui provient de l'absence de
qr code lisible sur les applications
françaises
nous avons deux process de mise en
oeuvre d'un qr code qui sont en cours de
travail
le gouvernement s'est engagé à ce qu à
la date de promulgation de la loi ce
problème technique soit réglée et donc
tous les français à l'étranger vaccinés
par des vaccins reconnu en europe auront
leur cuvée coeur code en bonne et due
forme c'est une question de jours
pour les français à l'étranger qui n'ont
pas eu des vaccins reconnu c'est bien ça
dont on parle un peu français qui à
l'étranger n'ont pas reçu de vaccin qui
sont requis sont valides valide en
europe ou en france pour ces
personnes-là le gouvernement travaille
avec les autorités scientifique
compétente pour trouver une solution
pour voir si une seule dose de vaccin
arn messagers pourrait permettre par
exemple de les protéger c'est un schéma
qui est reconnu par le ms et donc nous y
travaillons avec une priorisation qui
pourrait être accordée à ces français de
l'étranger
par ailleurs or ces cas les français de
l'étranger avec une sérologie positive
peuvent bénéficier d'une seule dose de
vaccin pour au bout de sept jours être
parfaitement protégé circulent avec le
pass sanitaires par définition si vous
avez des anticorps c'est que vous avez
eu ou une dose de vaccin ou que j'avais
une copine donc vous avec une seule
injection en rentrant en france et vous
pouvez circuler librement au bout de 7
jours télé pas empêché de revenir on
vous demande de faire les tests pour
vérifier comme on le demande à toutes
les personnes enfin c'est une question
de cohérence et donc dernier élément
mesdames et messieurs les députés par
cohérence imaginons une seconde que vous
votiez cet amendement malgré encore une
fois les avis scientifiques
si vous votez cet amendement moi je ne
sais pas comment je demande un français
vivant en france pour avoir son pass
sanitaire de réaliser ces deux
vaccinations
parce que lui me dira le grenoblois me
diras m'attendais moi je le connais il
ya un an j'ai des anticorps parce que
j'habite grenache ne perdront pas
salutaire alors si je veux être san
francisco je l'aurai
enfin jeu honnêtement en cohérence je
suis même pas sûr que si on était
attaquée devant une juridiction on
puisse gagner
donc en fait on explose c'est qu'il y
aura plus de système de pass alitée ou
de validation d'immunité conférer
nécessitant de dose ou une infection
plus windows donc encore une fois je
comprends le problème
on s'est engagés on y travaille que le
quai d'orsay on en a parlé ce matin un
conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale on va mettre le paquet pour
permettre aux français et étrangers de
venir dans les meilleures conditions
je le redis aujourd'hui ils peuvent
venir une dose de vaccin en arrivant une
semaine plus tard le problème est réglé
on a solution tout les pros tous les
problèmes techniques et si vous votez ça
vous fait une entorse fait une entorse à
ce qu'on fait depuis le début de la
gestion de crise sanitaire
c'est à dire nous baser sur la science
pour prend des décisions politiques
merci monsieur mieux alors j'ai deux
demandes de parole et d'eux seuls
monsieur bêche et madame et la rage d'un
2 demain il n'y a pas de ces métiers
belgique a demandé la parole avant tout
le monde
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
alors j'entends vos arguments monsieur
le ministre mais en même temps on en
perd un peu son latin parce que si vous
voulez on nous dit il faut faire
plusieurs doses de vaccin parce que
c'est ce qui nous permet d'avoir
l'immunité de hockey l'immunité
on la mesure comment on la mesure
normalement en taux d'anticorps par
unité demi litre dans le sang
bon donc à partir de là on devrait être
capable sur un test sérologique
je ne dis pas pour arriver en france je
ne dis pas pour rentrer en france jeudi
une fois qu'on est sur le territoire
français de faire un test sérologique
reconnu par un laboratoire français qui
permet de montrer quel est le niveau
d'anticorps et là soit on est couvert
on a un niveau suffisant ou alors on n'a
pas un niveau suffisant
ce que vous nous dites c'est de dire en
fait on a des français vous quand même
voir là la matérialité des choses nous
avons des gens qui se sont fait vacciner
que nous avons incité à se faire
vacciner à l'étranger des français
vaccinés notamment nos ambassades
ils se sont mis deux doses de vaccin
spoutnik si nos facs état
dans le bras ben si hélas hélas ils
reviennent en france et on leur dit va
falloir en mettre encore une dame axa
arn messagers c'est ce que vous venez
nous dire pour pouvoir être couverts
nous ce que nous proposons avec la maman
de notre collègue john t c'est d'avoir
un système très simple basé sur la
sérologie qui permettent à partir de
critères objectifs qu'il appartiendra
aux autorités de santé de définir que un
qr code puisse leur être donné avec non
pas une équivalence entre les vaccins
mais une immunité qui permet de montrer
qu'on est protégée contre le comider cas
si on protège des autres c'est ce que
nos monuments et nous voterons en faveur
de cet amendement merci merci madame et
la rage monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie pour cette réponse assez
exhaustive mais qui pour autant appelle
un certain nombre de questions on l'a
évoqué hier en commission
déjà je ya deux sujets le premier sur la
question des la matérialité des faits
j'attire quand même notre attention
collective sur le fait qu'il ya un
certain nombre de françaises et de
français vivant à l'étranger qui se sont
pliés effectivement enjeux de la
vaccination alors pas forcément en
ambassade ça peut être aussi auprès des
autorités locales qui ont eu un vaccin
non reconnue aujourd'hui par l'agencé
européenne du médicament reconnu pour
autant par le ms certains efficacité
amoindrie par rapport à ceux reconnus
par l' agence européenne du médicament
et qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas
contrats en france faute de cette
vaccination suffisantes donc vous dites
pourquoi pas une troisième dose arn
messagers je trouve que c'est une
solution qui pourrait être envisageable
simplement concernant la matérialité des
faits comment est ce qu'on a sur cette
vaccination est ce que ça veut dire très
concrètement qui sont en capacité de
prendre rendez-vous en centre de
vaccination est ce que cette injection
est prise en charge par l'assurance
maladie au même titre que les autres
français ou pas ensuite autre question
sur la question du statut sérologique ça
m'interroge quand même un petit peu
puisque le statut sérologique
aujourd'hui permet quand même de donner
un certain nombre d'informations
scientifiques sur la question de
l'infection ou non est donc un exemple
une interrogation très concrètes
quelqu'un qui a eu le coc vide
aujourd'hui il faut un certain laps de
temps avant qu'ils puissent être
vaccinés ce laps de temps il est estimé
par l'évaluation de son statut
sérologique donc ça contredit un petit
peu ce que ce que vous dites à quelqu'un
est ce que vous pourriez nous éclairer
là dessus et si tout cela n'est pas
possible
quelles solutions pourrions nous
envisager parce qu'il me semble que
c'est quand même un sujet éminemment
important il ya un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens qui vivent à l'étranger et
qui depuis maintenant presque deux ans
n'ont pas pu rentrer ou sont empêchés
pour des raisons sanitaires
et c'est quand même important c'est une
détresse qu'il faut prendre en compte
est la question du droit du sol est
aussi éminemment importante à savoir le
droit de pouvoir rentrer chez soi en
france voilà alors je rappelle qu'il ya
une demande de ce que tu as les deux
orateurs sont exprimés c'est pas la
peine
il yaa par monsieur le ministre je vois
des députés qui demande la parole non
les deux orateurs sont exprimés mais ses
ministres j'ai été interrogé et mais je
voudrais notamment répondre répondre au
président olivier becht vous donner des
éléments factuels d'abord vous dire que
j'adorerais on aimerait tous dans sur la
planète qu'un niveau d'anticorps contre
le coc vide soit déterminant pour savoir
si la personne est protégée pour te
convient d' or nous n'avons pas la
réponse
ça n'existe pas dans la science j'ai
même vous dire qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent je faire une
comparaison mais comparaison n'est pas
raison mais pour vous montrer les choses
pendant plusieurs mois en 1983 ou 1984
lorsqu'un virus inconnu a été découvert
qui s'appelait alors le vih lorsque les
gens avaient des sérologies qui était
positive
on leur annonçait qu'ils étaient
immunisés contre le vih et qu'il
risquait plus rien aujourd'hui ces
personnes par définition les appelle les
séropositifs c'est à dire des gens qui
ont des infections chroniques je vous
dis pas encore une fois que je compare
le vih locaux vides c'est juste vous
expliquer que la science doit nous
rendre modeste et que y'a des fois on
aimerait bien que le bon sens prévale
avec les virus
enfin si le bon sens vanek locaux vides
on serait au courant depuis le temps
donc je ne vous dis que nous n'avons
aucune réponse d'aucune autorité
sanitaire international permettant de
corréler un niveau d'anticorps conféré
ou une infection en ciel ou un vaccin
avec le niveau de protection dans la
durée contre locaux vides 19 ce qu'on
sait c'est que si vous avez une qu'ovide
et une dose de vaccin ça marche
si vous avez eu deux doses de vaccin ça
marche mais si vous avez une séquelle de
co vide
on venait vous avez un niveau de
protection qui est très variable et si
vous n'avez aucune injection
vous avez un niveau de protection qui
est très faible moi j'ai compris
mesdames et messieurs les députés qu'on
nous demandait de protéger notre
territoire de faire en sorte que j'ai le
moins possible de personnes contaminées
qui arrivent nous d'autant qu'à
l'étranger des variantes peuvent émerger
si maintenant on me dit qu'il faut être
très protecteurs contre toutes les
personnes sauf vis-à-vis de toutes les
personnes mais que s'agissant des
français de l'étranger c'est pas grave
on va faire le pari que les sérologies
indique la protection je vous dis juste
que si on veut être parfaitement
cohérent vis à vis de nos concitoyens
laisser faites nous confiance nous fait
tout confiance 1 pour répondre oui
les vaccins seront évidemment pris en
charge de vous le savez les tests et je
le rappelle ici
les tests sont pris en charge pour les
français de l'étranger il ya la gratuité
des soins qui leur est conférée trois
personnes est empêché de rentrer sur le
territoire je le redis il leur faut
juste un test quand ils ne sont pas
quand ils n'ont pas l'immunité acquise
par des vaccins 4 nous encourageons oui
les français de l'étranger à se faire
vacciner là où ils sont en lien que les
ambassades et les consulats à la grande
différence monsieur ben cheikh ce que
vous avez dit qu'on les encourage et que
tous les vaccins qu'on leur fournissons
des vaccins homologués par l' agence
européenne du médicament pas ce serait
totalement incohérent de dire un
français qui vit en france
il faut qu'il soit vacciné par des bars
des vaccins sûrs et efficaces mais un
français qui vit à l'étranger c'est pas
grave
non il n'y a pas de français de seconde
zone ils ont droit à la même protection
et l'ensemble de nos concitoyens a le
droit de suivre les mêmes règles avec
les mêmes droits et les mêmes devoirs
croyez moi nous allons apporter une
solution rapide pour les français de
l'étranger en matière de vaccination
merci monsieur minutes alors sur cet
amendement chacun se souvient qu'un
scrutin public
on va par mais c'est pas possible
et là
le scrutin
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
résultat
votants 236 exprimé 204 majorité à 103
pour 89 contre 115 l'amendement est
rejeté nous en venons au 781 monsieur
best healy à un scrutin public également
son serment de marie c c'est exactement
c'est exactement la même chose on va
retenter une deuxième fois mais encore
une fois enfin si vous voulez nous on en
perd notre latin je ne comprends pas
l'argument qui n'est pas le vôtre
monsieur ministre qui est celui des
autres autorités de santé je vous remets
pas en cause personnellement vous faites
un travail extraordinaire
et si si mais je tiens à le dire je
tiens à dire jr vous avez passé toute la
nuit en commission vous êtes toute la
nuit ici avec nous car voilà donc je
salue votre travail mais j'avoue que je
ne comprends pas la logique de dire il
ya certains vaccins à deux doses mais on
sait pas si ça protège aussi ça protège
pas il ya un moment il faut rester
cohérent avec la question de la
vaccination
si la vaccin protège alors il faut
pouvoir mesurer cette protection est
mesurée cette protection a priori c'est
les niveaux d'anticorps
donc moi je remets le débat aujourd'hui
sur la table parce que on a un sujet qui
est majeure comment faire en sorte que
3,5 millions de français de l'étranger
qui nous regardent puisse revenir en
france et avoir une vie à peu près
normale sachant qu'ils sont déjà
vaccinés qu'ils ont deux doses et qu'ils
ne pourront pas se mettre à nouveau de
doses d'un autre vaccin
donc on a un problème qui est
fondamentalement un problème
logique mais qui est aussi un problème
politique vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
donc je vous engage à voter cet
amendement merci mais non merci monsieur
le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président continue du
vote précédent ce sera un avis de
sagesse monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le fur qui ne se plaindra
plus monsieur le président merci
lorsque je voudrais simplement dire
c'est que sur ce sujet est extrêmement
sensible pour un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes extrêmement sensible ils
sont à l'étranger
ils ont le mérite de travailler pour
nous pour nos entreprises à l'étranger
et certains couples aujourd'hui sont de
fait ces paris light à l'étranger
l'autre est en france ils ne se sont pas
vus pour certains depuis plusieurs mois
avoir plus d'un an
le sujet c'est comment cette personne à
l'étranger va pouvoir revenir dans
certains pays il ne lui est pas proposée
les vaccins dont nous disposons chez
nous donc il a été vaccinées selon
d'autres critères qui ne sont pas
peut-être reconnu par nos instances
en tout état de cause il faut trouver le
moyen de lui permettre de revenir
l'une des solutions que vous évoquiez
monsieur le ministre est là je voudrais
mettre en exergue votre contradiction
c'est que vous dites
pour celui-là on pourra admettre qu'une
primo vaccination quand il arrivera en
france sera pertinente pour lui
permettre de bénéficier du pass
sanitaires là je ne comprends plus
monsieur le ministre ce que la
primovaccination vous l'a contesté pour
les français de l'hexagone et vous
l'admettrez riez pour les français
revenant la primovaccination vous avez
tort de la refuser pour le pape
sanitaire parce que vous créez une
discrimination une discrimination
essentiellement à l'égard des gens entre
20 et 35 ans puisque c'est cela qui
n'ont pas été prioritaires dans le
schéma vaccinal que nous avons adoptée
donc ils sont au début de leur processus
et je vois refuser la possibilité de
bénéficier d'un pass sanitaires donc
vous allez avoir des générations ou les
personnes plus âgées pour entrer dans un
bar mais le fils qui les accompagnera et
qui aura simplement fait sa première
vaccine
sion ne pourra pas comment vous
expliquer ça aux familles
eh bien je voudrais te laisserai le soin
de l'expliquer merci monsieur viguier
nommé très rapidement mais c'est le
président ce ministre lorsque vous dites
un niveau d'anticorps suffisant mais ne
savez comme moi qui dans une rubéole
dans une toxoplasmose
quand vous avez fait la maladie et car
vous rendez le résultat après vous avez
un taux protecteur un taux limite ou un
taux qui ne protège pas ça c'est ce
qu'on fait des labos des milliers
d'examens par jour ça se passe comme ça
dans le pays et pour chaque pathologie
pour le sida c'est la même chose
et pour ceux qui ont fait une copine en
réanimation il y en a qui sortent avec
1000 unités d'hôtes à 40
et si ça vous intéresse je vous donnerai
sur 2000 patients randomisés puisqu'il
chez moi nous les suivons et vous verrez
les histogrammes de répartition et donc
lorsqu'on nous dit vous avez un tout
protecteur c'est un taux qui peut être
décidée de façon commune par les
laboratoires et qui assure une immunité
qui protège une surinfection ces raisons
pour laquelle me permet de dire que ce
niveau de ton protecteur est un niveau
qui est reconnu par ceux qui chaque jour
connaissent ce genre de problème merci
alors sauce et d'amendements 780 avis
défavorable de monsieur le ministre et
sagesse de monsieur le rapporteur il ya
une demande de scrutin public cette
chute a va intervenir maintenant c'est
pas la peine de il y a deux orateurs
point pense que tout le monde l'a
compris c'est pas la peine d'essayer de
d'impressionner qui que ce soit en
essayant de d'appeler la parole voilà je
vous le dis je sais c'est quelque chose
qui m'insupporte ça on a des règles on
essaye de les uns et les autres de les
respecter
bon alors 780 un avis défavorable de
monsieur le ministre
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
votants 239 exprimé 210 majorité sans
siffler pour 87 contre 123 l'amendement
est rejeté le 895 l'éts il défendu il ne
l'est pas le 11 64 prend-il merci merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre est amendements visent à
rajouter est complété à l'alinéa 6 la
phrase suivante par exception une
attestation professionnels dérogatoire
vos justificatifs de déplacement à
partir du moment où la personne peut
travailler
on estime qu'elle est qu'elle qu'elle
n'est pas qu'elle ne met pas en danger
les gens qui sont autour d'elle
je vous remercie fille mercy voilà on va
entendre monsieur le monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président c'est un
avis défavorable il s'agit du
déplacement etc travail jacno qui
peuvent être anticipées programmée merci
je demande vraiment j'ai un titre au
prix de chacun d'entre vous un peu de
silence à serait ce que pour s'entendre
madame la ministre n'est pas grave je le
mets au voile euros 64 qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejeté le soc est monsieur leye
et si vous l'acceptez monsieur des
mercis avec le 108
oui merci monsieur le président il
s'agit de demander le maintien des tests
pcr pour les personnes qui se rendent à
la réunion et bien sûr la gratuité du
test pcr le 108 est un amendement de
repli qui demande la même chose pour les
personnes justifiant d'un intérêt et
moraux matériels dans les collectivités
qui sont mentionnés à l'article 72
alinéa 3 merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur
donc pour les deux un moment ce sera un
avis défavorable puisque le dépistage
mais logique est déjà gratuit
quelles que soient les conditions tout
comme la vaccination ne paraît pas
opportun d'introduire une différence de
traitement pour les déplacements vers
les yeux promet donc à vis des favoris
si madame la ministre
même le bon merci monsieur le président
donc je vais soutenir mon collègue
mallet et revenir à la charge concernant
les autres maires il ne s'agit pas
d'avoir une phase il s'agit d'ailleurs
d'avoir une différence de traitement
puisqu'il ya des spécificités propres à
nos territoires et la population attend
des réponses spécifiques qui dépasse de
loin la prolongation d' état d'urgence
sanitaire vous nous dites que des tests
pcr sont gratuits jusqu'à quand elle
attend la population d'être entendu
quant aux inquiétudes qu'il faut écouter
pour les comprendre et pour y répondre
et tant que vous ne le ferez pas je suis
désolé de vous le dire mais vous serez à
côté leurs préoccupations et la
population elle non plus ne vous
écoutera pas merci madame la députée je
vais mettre aux voix fut créée seulement
ces amendements le france est d'abord
avis défavorable de madame la ministre
et de monsieur le rapporteur qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté le faillite mais ma vie
qui est pour et qui est contre vos
ajouté le 1001 manama gary merci
président il s'agit par c'est vraiment
un moment de reporter l'entrée en
vigueur du pass à lithaire au 30
septembre
comme on l'a fait part en commission
pour les pour les mineurs donc au 30
septembre que ce soit pour les mineurs
et les majeures et il me semble que vu
l'incertitude qui qui qui pèse
sur le stock des vaccins on a l'a vu ce
qui se passait en bonne santé dans le
nord où le pas de calais on a parlé tout
à l'heure
il me semble que et les difficultés
aussi de d'obtention de premier
rendez-vous pour toute la population
il semble que le délai pour le spa
sanitaires devraient être retardés
merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre je mets au voile
amendement 2000 un avis défavorable de
madame la ministre et de monsieur le
rapporteur qui et pour qui et contre qui
les rejeter monsieur rue fin 2012
jb c'est un article de france diplomatie
qui écrit jean-yves le drian était en
visite officielle en inde du 13 au 15
avril
ce déplacement témoigne de la vitalité
du partenariat stratégique entre la
france et l'inde
certes il y avait la vitalité du
partenariat mais on sait qu'à la même
époque il y avait surtout une très
grande vitalité du variant indiens ont
baptisé variant delta il était
évidemment pas seul il ya des milliers
de business man de touristes et ainsi de
suite qui effectué le même voyage et il
nous semble que ça pose problème est
d'ailleurs votre votre ministre lui-même
clément bonne qui passait par roissy a
pu noter le 3 juillet dernier
personne n'était là pour vérifier si les
passagers du vol air france avaient
leurs passes sanitaire en bon et due
forme par le moindre fonctionnaires de
police ni salariés d'aéroports de paris
pour s'assurer que chacun était vacciné
au tester ça me rappelle le moment où on
a confiné la côte d'azur
parce que en même temps en même temps on
avait dans l papier qui décrivait
l'aéroport de nice où les vols
internationaux décollaient et
atterrissaient sans test et sans
contrôle d'où cet amendement qui suggère
que il soit permis au premier ministre
d'interdire les voyages à destination ou
en provenance de pays où circulent
invariants encore non détectées sur le
sol français
si monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre
je le mets aux voix qui est pour à
eysines sur une fin il me semble que sur
cette question
voyez qu'est ce qu'on fait pour la
circulation des variants à l'échelle
internationale quand on a des cartes du
ciel où ça circule dans tous les sens on
peut quand même avoir une réponse sur
les grands de circulation étaient ce
qu'on fait pour le libre échange des
variants tout à l'heure il ya une
discussion sur les transports qui mérite
aussi quand même question comment ça se
fait que le variant va circuler en tgv
du coup y afférentes pas sanitaire mais
que le variant va pas de circuler en ter
on a quand même des questions qui
méritent une réponse merci je mets aux
voileux 1012 mais fut le fur des
questions qui se posent dans ce domaine
regardons ce qui se passe entre les
états unis et la france
les américains refusent de fait
l'arrivée des français
nous acceptons de fait l'arrivée des
américains un moment donné il faut un
minimum de cohérence dans les rapports
entre pays
il s'agit pas de se protéger à l'excès
mais il s'agit également d'avoir un
caractère un peu un peu simple dans les
rapports entre les les collectifs et les
pays qui nous entourent
merci jeu mais on voit le 1012 quai pour
qui est contre il est rejeté des villes
antiques lequel sa 1re flaubert pays
merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui est un peu dans la même
philosophie
on va bien que depuis le début de cette
crise on ne se préoccupe pas des
frontières
moralité il faut pas s'étonner ensuite
s'ils nous avons tous les variantes du
monde qui débarque puisque je rappelle
quand même qu'à l'origine lorsque
l'italie était affecté contaminer leur
fusion de fermer la frontière avec
l'italie et c'est finalement l'italie
cafards mais la frontière de son côté ce
qui fait les italiens pouvaient venir en
france et les français ne pouvaient pas
venir en italie dans cet amendement
il est proposé de conditionner l'entrée
sur le territoire français pour des
étrangers au fait qu'ils soient vaccinés
c'est à dire il mesures plus
restrictives que le pass sanitaires je
crois que c'est une mesure qui s'impose
qui permet de répondre à la question qui
était posée tout à l'heure de ladite la
libre circulation des variants et sinon
et bien mort né en fera un arbitrage
tacon à préfailles confiner les français
quelque part le relever leur liberté
d'aller et venir sur leur propre
territoire pour laisser les frontières
ouvertes c'est-à-dire laisser finalement
les flux internationaux
moi je préférerais un arbitrage
différent où on fait un travail aux
frontières ce qui permet de protéger les
français à l'intérieur du territoire
merci le phisheur 9 même cher n'est pas
des plans du monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président je souhaite
que nous obtenions dispositif prévu d'un
par le cadre du passeport vert européen
le décret du 1er juin préval prévues
prévoient néanmoins avec des conditions
d'arrivée plus sévères pour les
personnes non vaccinées comme des
arrêtés de mise en quarantaine lorsqu'il
le viennent de zones rouges avis
défavorable dit monsieur rapporteur
madame la ministre
merci monsieur aubert merci monsieur le
président j'entends bien l'argument qui
est un argument fonctionnelle de dire en
fait l'europe a décidé que le pass
serait ainsi est donc finalement il faut
faire comme ça dans ce cas là que
faisons-nous dans cet hémicycle tard
dans la nuit si c'est uniquement pour
reproduire les instructions qui nous
viennent non je rappelle que malte avait
souhaité limiter l'entrée des étrangers
avec une seule vaccination
sous la pression de la commission
européenne elle est revenue en arrière
mais ça c'est pas un argument juridique
ou un argument médicale c'est un
argument purement politiques à un moment
donné en tant que député de la nation
nous devons nous poser la question si
une protection aux plus grandes ne doit
pas être ouverte à l'égard de tourisme
de résidents étrangers qui sont
parfaitement informés avant de venir sur
le territoire qui se feront vacciner
c'est la meilleure manière d'éviter je
le dis que d'importer tous les variants
du monde faudra pas s'étonner si nous
avons demain des variants québécois
indien
qu'on a déjà d'ailleurs ou australiens
compte tenu du fait que nous ne faisons
aucun contrôle et ça avait commencé dès
l'époque avec la chine ou je rappelle qu
alors que le coe vide exposé en chine
il y avait strictement aucun contrôle
dans nos aéroports on peut pas un moment
donné pleurer sur des conséquences dont
on chérit les causes
merci je mets aux voix je mets au voile
amendement 400 avis défavorable de
madame la ministre et de monsieur le
rapporteur qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté monsieur le député
philippe dallier le sens s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le président rapidement
rappelé que pour le territoire de la
réunion l'aéroport a été la porte du
virus et de ses variantes
malgré la mise en place du premier test
pcr dès la réouverture de l'aéroport
force est de constater que la maladie
puis ces variants été importés si je
puis dire sur l'île à cause des failles
du corridor portail sanitaire mis en
place par ce qu'il faut mais autant
mettre fin la circulation du virus sur
l'île en incitant l'informant sur les
gestes la forme et informer la
population sur les gestes barrières sur
la vaccination sans diviser par exemple
que s'assurer que de nouveaux cas et
surtout de nouvelles souches n'entre sur
notre territoire
cet amendement permet donc que les
personnes non vaccinées ou ne pouvant
présenter un certificat de
rétablissement suite à une récente
contamination réalise un second test pcr
à l'issue de la période d'isolement
prévu à l'arrivée
merci monsieur le rapporteur
il ne me paraît pas opportun de tester
les personnes à leur arrivée c'est bien
au départ qu'il faut le faire donc avis
défavorable madame la ministre je mets
je mets aux voix l'amendement de
monsieur nay et le sens si ce qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté madame dupont le le 1144
et le 1140 triche tout à fait monsieur
le président merci madame la ministre
chers collègues je je je je représente
ici mon collègue olivier servat qui est
retenu en guadeloupe et qui par ces deux
amendements fait valoir
comme d'autres collègues l'ont fait les
intérêts spécifiques et l'espèce est
enfin les spécificités pardon des
territoires d'outre-mer et de la
guadeloupe en particulier et propose par
ces deux amendements que des ajustements
par voie réglementaire soit possible
pour s'adapter justement aux
spécificités de ces territoires
je vous remercie merci monsieur le le
rapporteur
même si le président j'entends bien les
préoccupations que vous soulevez mais
compte tenu du dépôt d'un amendement du
gouvernement visant à déclarer l'état
d'urgence sanitaire en guadeloupe je
vous propose un retrait au bénéfice des
explications sur l'état de la situation
sanitaire locale et des réponses qui
sont apportées pour y remédier avis
défavorable merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur prudhomme
oui je vous remercie monsieur le
président juste pour revenir sur cette
séquence de trois amendements qui parle
d'une question qui est celle de la
gestion des flux et une fois n'est pas
coutume je partage l'analyse de monsieur
aubert du collègue robert même si je ne
prône pas les mêmes
la même gestion en tout cas des flux
entrants mais il est évident et c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui que les
contrôles à l'entrée du territoire sont
absolument inopérant et notamment sur
cette histoire du variant indien quand
les premiers cas et canteleu variés
indien a commencé à flamber
on nous a assuré la main sur le coeur
encore une fois faites nous confiance on
va contrôler les flux entrants tout le
monde va être super bien tester il se
passera rien manque de bol le 29 avril
le 29 avril chers collègues le premier
cas de variants indiens étaient détectés
dans le sud ouest
donc après on s'étonne d'être deux mois
après découvrir que le variant indien
flambent mais la question de la gestion
des flux est un point aveugle de votre
politique sanitaire
hélas le phédon ça la façon dont vous ne
répondez pas à ces questions de gestion
des flux que ce soit pour les outre-mer
pour l'étranger est symptomatique de
votre inconséquence à regarder les
choses telles qu'elles se passe
réellement dans la vraie vie sur le
terrain et notamment dans les aéroports
dans les ports dans les gares et donc ça
c'est quand même assez inquiétant sur la
suite je vous rappelle premiers
canadiens 29 avril alors nous racontez
pas non plus que maintenant il faudrait
dans la nuit gérer toute cette
inconséquence
merci je vais mettre voir le 11 44 avis
défavorable de madame la ministre et de
monsieur le rapporteur qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejeté le 11 46 quai pour qu'ils
contre il est rejeté nous en venons vous
fait 121 monsieur pradier
merci monsieur le président nous en
sommes au stade de cet article toujours
à débattre de la question de
l'opportunité politique et sanitaire du
pass sanitaires dont je voudrais y
revenir une nouvelle fois j'ai une
opposition franche à la question du pass
sanitaires et je voudrais madame la
ministre que au nom du ministre vous
puissiez éclairé de propos qu'il a tenus
tout à l'heure le ministre a dit tout à
l'heure que dès lors qu' il y avait une
population largement vacciner il n'y
avait plus de virus sa phrase exacte a
été lorsque tout le monde est vacciné il
n'y a plus de virus je cite à la au mot
près je voudrais que vous puissiez
confirmé cette phrase là parce qu'elle
me paraît ou totalement irresponsable ou
parfaitement mensongère est-ce que vous
pouvez affirmer devant la représentation
nationale que si il y à 100 % de la
population vaccinée
alors il n'y a plus de circulation du
virus je ne suis pas un spécialiste
sanitaire de la question cette phrase là
vous pouvez vous consultez madame la
ministre avec les conseillers qui vous
entourent elle a été scrupuleusement
prononcée par le ministre à deux
reprises tout à l'heure la deuxième
phrase que je voudrais que vous
confirmiez parce que il ne s'agit pas
ici de raconter n'importe quoi
le ministre l'a dit aussi c'est le fait
que avec le pass sanitaires il n'y aura
pas de confinement
c'est la phrase qui a été prononcée à
nouveau par le ministre tout à l'heure
c'est ou le pass sanitaires ou les
opérations de confinement
puisque vous voulez faire preuve de
rigueur puisque nos concitoyens nos
écoutes réaffirmer ici clairement que
s'il ya le pass sanitaires il n'y a pas
d'euro il n'y aura pas de confinement si
je vous pousse à cette précision là
c'est parce que depuis quelques temps et
depuis quelques heures il me semble que
vous prenez de grandes libertés avec la
rigueur et avec l'information nos
concitoyens m il me fait le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
et danger deux demandes de paroles déjà
la merci du président je ne reviens pas
sur l'intérêt sanitaires du passé et
l'outil décisif qu'il constitue donc son
avis défavorable mais à mon humble avis
si on
prend le pas sanitaires c'est pour
éviter le confinement et d'autres
mesures plus sévères et pour essayer d
éviter
merci madame madame la ministre monsieur
le député pradier le seul ministre n'a
fait que dire que c'est seulement
l'immunité collective qui nous permettra
d'arrêter la circulation du virus est
vous l'avez très bien entendu comme moi
si c'était ça vous vouliez m'entendre
dire et nous sommes tous évidemment ce
soir en tout cas j'espère pour un
déconfinement généralisée et donc pour
éviter que la circulation de continue à
ce rythme là et c'est ce qu'il a dit il
n'a dit que cela film tu être fait merci
beaucoup monsieur le président madame la
ministre
notre collègue radié à poser une
question très précise et en réalité vous
ne répondez pas à cette question précise
et je voudrais du coup aussi insisté sur
un point que vous avez à l'instant
mentionné
vous nous dites le pass sanitaire c'est
finalement le pare feu au développement
d'un confinement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ici que
le pass sanitaires pour le gouvernement
c'est la certitude qu'il n'y aura pas de
confinement
vous voyez bien vous voyez mais
justement vous voyez bien que ce
raisonnement est absurde parce que le
pire qui puisse nous attendre c'est
d'abord le pass sanitaire puis le
confinement et donc nous allons nous
retrouver dans une situation peut être
bien pire que ce que vous aviez plus là
aussi imaginer donc là aussi choyés un
moment donné logique
en réalité vous ne voulez pas je fumais
les choses et une nouvelle fois ce que
vous êtes en train de faire vous
fracturé le pays parce que en réalité
qu'est ce qui va se passer
vous ne voulez pas assumer le fait en
réalité que tout le monde passe par une
vaccination obligatoire puisque en fait
votre pass sanitaire ça n'est ni plus ni
moins que de faire en sorte que la
population soit obligé de se vacciner
sans quoi elle
pourra pas vivre normalement merci
messieurs le tchèque
merci monsieur le président si on veut
que ce pass sanitaire c'est parce qu'on
espère qu'il va être efficace
je reviens sur la question que j'avais
posé avant l'interruption de qu'elle
passe sanitaire parlons nous parce que
le pass sanitaire qui en application que
nous avons été ici pour les types et
prévoir en l'occurrence un contrôle de
l'identité des personnes qui déposent
leurs passes or il a été annoncé
aujourd'hui que pour certains
établissements il n'y aura pas le
contrôle de l'identité
on a déjà vu depuis quinze jours là où
le pass est obligatoire avec l'appui
d'entités il ya déjà des failles dans le
système avec des faux documents qui sont
faits
demain si il y à se passe sans le
contrôle d'identité dans certains lieux
et je ne veux pas parler des lieux de
jour où je pense que c'est moins
problématique mais les lieux de nuit
s'il n'y a pas de contrôle i doté avec
le pasa donnera plein de faux donc dans
ce cas là qu'est ce qui est prévu et
donc si on veut se passe on veut
efficacité or avec ce qui a été annoncé
aujourd'hui on risque d'avoir moins
d'efficacité dont je voudrais savoir à
un moment
lequel passe sanitaire est ce que l'on
parle et la deuxième chose se passe
sanitaire il prévoit le contrôle à
l'entrée ou sur table du pass pour voir
si on est vert ou rouge
mais après il prévoit aussi que la
personne scanne le lieu de
l'établissement ce n'est fait car
actuellement que dans les casinos qui
ont l'obligation de le faire et qu'ils
le font et qu'ils vérifient comment est
ce que demain le gouvernement entend
faire appliquer cela parce que c'est le
passé interio prévoir tout cela sinon ça
ne peut pas fonctionner merci alors je
maintenant je mets aux voix le 721 avis
défavorable de madame la ministre et de
monsieur le rapporteur qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est résulté madame fiat
madame pendant 19 semaines à bruz ben
merci monsieur président moi je me
souviens que à propos donc des vaccins
des français de l'étranger
le ministre a dit que le vaccin ne
garantissait pas l'immunité que le taux
d'anticorps ne voulait pas dire que l'on
était immunisé et pourtant baissé ce
qu'il a dit et il a pas si tort que ça
qu'on savait simplement qu'on constatait
empiriquement telle ou telle chose
moi je vous demande où est la médecine
là dedans un alors étendre le pass
sanitaires c'est à dire de façon tout à
fait hypocrite obligé à se vacciner
quand on n'est même pas sûr d'avoir dit
militer mais c'est vraiment une
tartufferie mais si c'est ce qu'il a dit
et j'ai bien entendu il était très
attentif
par ailleurs le pass sanitaires il a
demandé pour les activités qu'ils aient
à payer demande et donc pour aller au
restaurant mais pas pour aller au
restaurant d'entreprise
il demandait comme ça d évoquer dans les
transports publics de longues distances
mais pas pour le rer bond et je sais de
quoi je parle
mais est ce que c'est une politique
sanitaire peut vous mener la question
réelle et sérieuse
nous traitons d'un sujet sérieux d'une
pandémie et alors là vous nous faites
quelque chose
plein de contradictions plein de
contradictions et alors monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre puisque
vous êtes là hein parce que vous nous
avez dit qu'il fallait ou faire
confiance mais c'est pas le livre de la
jungle ici avec le serpent de cas faites
moi confiance est ma confiance
j'aimerais vous faire confiance dites
moi pourquoi si je mange au restaurant
d'entreprise
je ne risque rien et que je risque quand
je prends un pot avec le même collègues
le soir je remercie merci même la
députée monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
film sur ip roig ont simplement pour
dire que s'il y a déjà un premier
élément positif au pass sanitaires c'est
l'accélération de la vaccination
depuis les déclarations du président de
la république moi je j'avais quand même
un léger problème
je sais pas vous les mères qui était
titulaire on va dire fac y avait sur
leur territoire des centres de
vaccination me disaient ils commencent à
être vide il ya de moins en moins de
vaccination les les rendez-vous sont de
moins en moins tenu et ça nous bloque
des salles qui seront utiles pour nos
associations qui sont utiles pour la vie
communale
tout ça pour avoir une vaccination en
forte chute et vient depuis les
déclarations du président et l'annoncent
du pass sanitaires je peux vous dire que
les choses ont changé et que dans ce
pays
nous vaccinons par millions des français
aujourd'hui encore plus de huit cent
mille français qui ont une vaccination
et nous sommes en train de redonner une
dynamique à la politique de vaccination
dans ce pays
rien que ça ça devrait nous réjouir
[Applaudissements]
je non madame ruel
oui oui oui il s'agit de vacciner tout
le monde ou d'avoir une politique de
lutte contre le coc vide
je voulais vraiment distinguer deux
choses parce que là je crois qu'à les
deux choses sont complètement n'ont plus
rien à voir au regard des propres même
du ministre que géorgie qui a dit tout à
l'heure que les vaccins ne garantissait
pas l'immunité que le taux d'anticorps
le taux d'anticorps ne garantit tepa ne
garantit pas l'immunité écouter
réécouter parce que vous avez dit
monsieur le ministre
alors est-ce qu'on est là pour dire
qu'il faut vacciner tout le monde ou est
ce qu'on est là pour trouver les moyens
sérieux de régler cette idée me moi je
me demande alors je mets aux voix le 619
monsieur le le rapporteur a exprimé un
avis défavorable ainsi que monsieur le
ministre qui est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté le 1090 maladie mauvais
merci monsieur le président que le
présent amendement visait à supprimer le
dispositif du pass sanitaires tels que
prévus par le gouvernement et à limiter
son utilisation au seul déplacement au
delà d'un rayon de 200 km autour du
domicile
cette limitation a été considérée comme
suffisamment large pour ne pas entraver
la liberté de la personne qui ne
souhaitent pas se faire vacciner tout en
limitant le déplacement des populations
entre les territoires on peut en effet
considérer qu'une personne trouve dans
un rayon de 200 kilomètres de son
domicile
son lieu de travail mais également les
commerces et les activités qui lui sont
nécessaires
merci madame la députée monsieur le le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président je perçois
pas l'intérêt de sanitaires cette mesure
car rien n est applicable lorsque la
personne reste dans un rayon de 200 km
donc c'est un avis défavorable le
rapporteur vous êtes invités quand vous
voulez dans les paysages arctiques et et
tu avais je me permets que monsieur le
ministre vous aussi d'ailleurs
je le mets aux voix qui est pour et qui
est contre
il est rejeté monsieur blanche est de 79
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit précédemment
quand on aura le pass sanitaires on
pourra enlever le masque à l'intérieur
pour autant depuis 15 mois ont dit les
gestes barrière le masque et se laver
les mains sont les meilleures solutions
pour combattre le virus
je pense que et on l'a vu avec le passé
une terre qui est déjà présent dans de
nombreux lieux depuis 15 jours et que le
virus continue à circuler parce que le
système n'est pas infaillible qui serait
utile de rappeler
oui vous pouvez enlever le mas une fois
vous avez passé vous avec votre pass a
été apporté à l'intéressement
mais si vous voulez que l'on abandonne
rapidement le patient terre on vous
conseille fortement de garder le masque
est de continuer à vous laver les mains
est il si possible respecter les gestes
barrière aller là la vérité et monsieur
le ministre je voudrais pas à prendre la
rhétorique de mon collègue jumelles mais
ça fait la troisième fois que je pose
une seule question sur les types n
les débits de boissons il a été annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'ils n'auront pas
l'obligation de la présentation d'une
pièce d'identité sur le passeport
vaccinale je pense que pour ce qui est
des débits de boisson deux jours ça ne
peut pas poser de problème
mais qu'en est il pour les débits de
boissons à dérogation tardive qui sont
aussi des pistes de danse potentiel et
vous connaissez aussi bien que moi même
si nous avons eu des points là dessus la
potentielle ça veut dire que typiquement
on aura des débits de boissons à
dérogation tardive où on pourra rentrer
avec un pass à iter sans pièce
d'identité donc avec toutes les
falsifications possible
et avec tous les risques inhérents
possible ou est ce que enfin on pourra
avoir une précision là dessus
est ce qu'il aurait une spécificité là
dessus je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur films
choisis non le 2 de l'article 1er de la
loi du 31 mai dispose déjà que le
premier ministre peut réglementer les
conditions d'accès et de présence du
public dans les yeux et donc il est un
avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre monsieur le député
blanchet votre question est parfaitement
légitime j'ai entendu vous avez entendu
une intervention du premier ministre au
trésor aujourd'hui cette intervention
appelle évidemment des précisions
techniques qui vont suivre
je ne peux pas vous les donner à cette
heure ci dans l'hémicycle je vous
promets que tous sous les 48 heures vous
les aurez mais interné alors je vais
prendre il ya plusieurs demandes de
parole je vais donner une minute une
minute
non monsieur je vous la donne pas du
tout il ya plusieurs demandes de parole
ni la moindre des choses c'est de
respecter aussi la possibilité pour tout
le monde s'exprimer et jusqu'à présent
vous n'avez pas été le dernier avant la
parole donc je vous donne la parole et
je donnerai pas madame intermédiaire à
monsieur blanchette à monsieur
dupont-aignan et à monsieur le fur qui
l'avait demandé avant moi j'ai pas de
chance quand c'est pour moi il ya plus
de quatre personnes et on a une mine
mais c'est pas grave
monsieur lemay s'est glissée apportant
votre réponse parce que moi ce que je
crains c'est que pour survendre le
passage du ter comme solution miracle
vous êtes en train de prendre des
risques pour tous les français là ce qui
a été dit tout à l'heure est extrêmement
important nous avons entendu l'idée que
une fois rentrés dans une zone contrôlée
par le passage du ter vous pouvez
enlever vos masques ça a été dit redit
et tout à l'heure le premier ministre a
expliqué je les vois ça m'a extrêmement
surpris que désormais quelqu'un qui
seraient vaccinés avec deux doses ne
serait plus considéré comme cas contacts
même s'il a vu des gens vaccinés or nous
savons contrairement ce que vous avez
affirmé thaler que même dans les pays où
il ya une année et dorment vaccination
il y à de nombreux cas de gens qui
retombe malades avec le co vide et pour
ma part c'est peut-être juste de la
malchance mais j'en connais déjà
plusieurs autour de moi dans mon
entourage je pense que ce
et sait faire que vous jouez avec le
pass à lithaire pour nous le vendre est
extrêmement dangereux et moi je vous
incite à revenir sur ses décisions
ça doit pas être le fait d'exception je
pense que dès lors qu'on rentre dans des
lieux fermés vue où on en est
aujourd'hui même de l'épidémie il faut
garder son masque il faut garder des
protections pas y compris son appât
sanitaires et de grâce revenez sur cette
phrase du premier ministre sur le cadet
des personnes qui serait plus considérée
comme me contacte car j'avais toujours
entendu que l'idée du roi du père est
extrêmement pour madame intermédiaire
oui merci monsieur le président en tout
cas de nous mon groupe soutiendra cet
amendement nous avons déjà en commission
des lois a fait valoir combien il était
important non pas d'opposer le pass
sanitaires et les mesures barrières
il faut bien évidemment travailler
ensemble sur ces dispositifs est temps
que la population n'est pas vacciné
largement il ne faut surtout pas
découragé les personnalités les jeunes
les adultes de ces gestes barrière alors
que on constate actuellement que s'il ya
une augmentation aussi de la
contamination
ce n'est pas seulement la contagiosité
du delta c'est aussi l'abandon de
mesures barrières parce qu'on nous vend
le pass sanitaires comme la solution
pour respirer sans masque alors que je
pense qu'on a une vraie responsabilité
sur un principe de précaution que l'on
doit absolument rappeler aux citoyens
c'est l'objet de notre intervention
nous saluons cet amendement et nous
espérons que tous ensemble
eh bien nous l'adopterons merci monsieur
blanchette nantes chez pardon
on parle gauche et le président il est
tard je comprends vous inquiétez pas
monsieur le ministre
voilà au delà de ce que et monsieur le
rapporteur ce que vous avez dit je pense
qu'il est urgent et mes collègues l'ont
rappelé d'envoyer un message de
communication en rappelant simplement
c'est pas parce que vous avez pas
sanitaire que vous devez enlever le
masque vous l'avez tout dit tout à
l'heure vous pouvez une fois à voir vous
avez eu le passé ni té vous pendant ce
temps un établissement est enlevé lé et
enlever le masque non vous pouvez
enlever le masque mais on vous le
déconseille fortement parce que plus
vous garderez le masque plus vous
laverez les mains même si vous n'avez
pas sanitaire que vous êtes dans un
endroit clos
plus vite on oubliera demain le pasteur
c'est ça le seul message qu'il faut
avoir
il faut une grande campagne de
communication est là dessus parce
qu'aujourd'hui les messages sur des
voiliers et beaucoup n'y comprennent
plus rien et se passe à iter apparaît
comme la solution finale pour avoir une
vie réelle la vie réelle c'est contre
vivra des victimes en cent pas sanitaire
sans vaccin et et s'en passe tout
simplement
donc voilà monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le député me fais dupont aignan
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
au fil de la soirée au fur et à mesure
des amendements on s'aperçoit des
contradictions permanentes
pourquoi 200 km pourquoi le tgv est pas
le métro on s'aperçoit qu'on se noie
dans les détails et qu'on oublie le
caractère profondément contraignant pour
plus de 20 millions de français qui vont
ne plus pouvoir circuler qui vont être
différents des autres qui vont être
exclu et véritablement j'ai l'impression
que l'on passe à côté de l'essentiel
mais au-delà de ça les contradictions du
gouvernement sont tellement forte
monsieur le ministre vous nous aviez dit
qu'il fallait pas mettre le masque au
début et puis après vous nous avez dit
qu'il fallait mettre le masque et puis
maintenant pour vendre le pass and it
erp comme la solution miracle
vous nous dites ah si vous êtes gentils
vous avez le pass sanitaire vous êtes
vacciné des gentils garçons gentils
fille à bob vous pourrez enlevé le
masque c'est complètement contradictoire
avec tout ce que disent les
scientifiques
donc comment par démagogie
pour vendre quelque chose une fausse
solution pour mettre à porter atteinte
aux libertés des français
vous inventez une sorte de bonus de
cadeaux c'est profondément irresponsable
en terme de santé publique et après vous
nous donner des leçons en disant que
vous sauver l'humanité que nous nous
sommes des horribles personnes qui
mettant en danger les vies alors que
vous dites aux gens supprimer le masque
voilà ce que vous avez dit merci
monsieur le président le fur monsieur le
président nous voterons évidemment cet
amendement déposé par notre collègue
blanchet mais sur le fond ce pass
sanitaire est une catastrophe
vous allez casser la croissance qui
était en train de reprendre
il est attentatoire aux libertés vous à
les opposer les français les uns aux
autres alors que votre fonction devrait
de rassembler et puis vous allez
transformer des commerçants en policier
ou un délateur bien ça nous n'en voulons
pas nous disons dix fois cent fois cent
fois oui à la vaccination
mais nous disons avec la même force cent
fois non au pass sanitaires c'est pour
ça qu'il faut absolument éviter cela à
tout prix et c'est pour ça que l'absurde
il est même reconnue par le premier
ministre qui explique qu'il faudra
présenter un qr code sans indiquer son
identité c'est le degré maximum de
l'absurde puisque très peu
d'établissements dispose de la
possibilité de lire les qr codes dont on
pourra rentrer dans un café en montrant
simplement ce document mais si c'est ce
qui se passe
vous avez jamais été dans un café au
coin
va travailler allez soyez un peu
attentif à ça vous dit merci
alors mes chers collègues choix qu'on
s'est largement exprimée je parle des
députés maintenant nous avons donné la
parole à monsieur le ministre et ensuite
on votera il ya eu plusieurs questions
de fond auquel je vais je vais tâcher de
répondre notamment c'était le député
coquerel qui a posé des questions déjà
répondu si dieu veut sur la question des
doubles vacciner qu'à contacter paca
contact encore une fois on a une
constante en ou caricature parfois pour
ça mais c'est pas grave on s'appuie sur
les recommandations scientifiques et
sanitaires pour prendre de décision et
vous appelez à prendre des décisions
avec nous
le haut conseil de santé publique était
saisi plusieurs fois sur la question de
savoir c'est quelqu'un qui est
totalement vacciner et donc protégée une
semaine après la deuxième injection
devait ou non être considérés comme cas
contacts s'ils étaient exposés au virus
le haut conseil de santé publique par le
ministère la santé
le haut conseil de santé publique nous a
écrit et réécrit réécrit qu'une personne
double vacciner une semaine après avoir
acquis la protection vaccinale si les
cas contacts d'une personne n'est pas
considéré comme cas contact n'a donc pas
à s'isoler et ne doit pas faire de tests
sauf s'ils présentent des symptômes
auquel cas il doit s'isoler et faire un
test et nous dit que si en revanche
cette personne totalement vacciner
protéger vit sous le même foyer dans le
même foyer qu'une personne qui positive
au co vide alors elle doit faire un test
limiter ces interactions sociales mais
n'est pas obligé de rester chez elle
considérant le haut conseil de santé
publique dit qu'effectivement il ya un
risque résiduel mais que le risque
résiduel est suffisamment faible que la
contagiosité des personnes qui sont
contaminées bien que double vacciner
est très faible et que ce risque
résiduel ne justifie plus de maintenir
les personnes double vacciner en
isolement et de leur imposer des tests
je vous donne l'état de la science c'est
transparent c'est publié sur le site du
ministère de la santé
et je n'ai pas de raison particulière de
contrevenir à cette disposition qui
émane d'un comité qui appuient qui
éclaire toutes nos décisions depuis un
an et demi y compris les décisions les
plus durs que vous avez été amené à
contester ce qui est votre droit
je vous ai répondu sur ce point là bien
sûr le deuxième point qu'en est il et je
reconnais que c'est compliqué on va
s'accrocher sur le port du masque dans
les établissements recevant du public
dans lequel est impliqué le pass
sanitaires il y avait deux situations
la situation des espaces extérieurs et
la situation des espaces intérieurs
à l'extérieur les choses sont claires le
masque des plus obligatoire ya eu des
festivals les choses se sont très bien
passé j'étais au festival solidays j'ai
eu d'autres choses
tout s'est très bien passé à l'intérieur
jusqu'ici nous avons considéré qu'il
fallait continuer à porter le masque à
nouveau le haut conseil de santé
publique sollicité et re solliciter
encore très récemment nous dit qu dans
la mesure où le pass sanitaire fait
l'objet d'une bonne application
le mot est important d'une bonne
application et dans le contexte
épidémique actuel il est licite de ne
plus considérer le port du masque comme
étant la règle y compris à l'intérieur
puisqu'il considère que là encore le
risque résiduel est très faible puisque
toutes les personnes qui se trouveront
dans une enceinte fermée seront aux
totalement vacciner et protège et ou
disposant d'un test récents montrant
qu'ils ne sont pas contaminés
j'ai reposé la question au conseil ce
qui m'arrive de temps en temps en 10 ans
avec le variant delta est ce que les
est-ce que les choses changent les
l'avis du haut conseil ne change pas
sous réserve qu'on soit capable de bien
faire respecter ce pass alité agen 6 sur
ce point et le décret qui a été publié
en conformité avec cet avis ce matin me
semble-t-il rappel ces éléments mais
renvoie aussi et la notion est
importante à la possibilité pour le
préfet
pour le préfet de maintenir obligatoire
le port du masque dans les départements
concernés c'est-à-dire qu'on voit bien
là qu'on a plutôt tendance à tenir
compte de la situation épidémique
nous allons voir avec l'ensemble des
préfets qu'elle sera l'application ou
territorialisée ou nationale s'agissant
du port du masque dans des enceintes
fermées soupa sanitaires j'ai envie de
vous dire que le taux d'incidence ayant
dépassé les 100 au niveau national il
est possible que nous demandions au
préfet de maintenir le port du masque
mais pas forcément partout dans les
endroits où le virus circule très peu en
cohérence encore une fois et parce que
c'est tout le sens du parce que de dire
si vous avez si vous êtes vacciné votre
vie ne va plus changé j'espère vous
avoir répondu là dessus maintenant
l'amendement que vous avez déposé
monsieur le député il nous dit il faut
maintenir les gestes barrière dans leur
ensemble et on renvoie au décret y
compris là où le bât sanitaire
s'applique y compris là où le bât
sanitaire ça pique ça veut dire que vous
nous ôter la plus haute et la
possibilité pour un préfet d'appliquer
les recommandations du haut conseil de
santé publique dans un département où le
virus circule très peu et de dire on
peut enlever le masque et en plus vous
inscrivez dans la loi ce qui veut dire
qu'il faudrait une nouvelle loi pour
casser ça quand bien même l'épidémie
s'effondrerait que tout le monde serait
sous passe sanitaire qu'on serait pas
loin et l'humilité populationnelle et
qu'objectivement il ne serait plus
nécessaire de maintenir le masque donc
ça je vous demande de ne pas le mettre
dans la loi parce que c'est
contreproductif par ailleurs si vous
votez cela ça veut dire aussi que demain
les discothèques devront rendre
obligatoire le port du masque sur les
pistes de danse
ce qui n'est pas le choix que nous avons
fait pour des raisons évidentes des plus
fins connaisseurs que ma discothèque
je n'espère pas qu'un jour on aura
l'occasion d'y aller ensemble
qui sait mais vous n'êtes plus
connaisseurs qu'eux mois et vous savez
bien que danser sur une piste de danse
et boire des coups en discothèque avec
le mas est impossible donc je vous
propose sur ses explications de retirer
votre amendement parce qu'il va
exactement à l'opposé de ce que vous
cherchez à faire
merci
monsieur min alors on va voter sur le
279 avis défavorable de monsieur le
ministre et de monsieur le rapporteur
qui est pour
non ok pour qui est contre il est rejeté
alors discussion commune le 171 monsieur
des coeurs sont en discussion commune
pour gagner un peu de temps il s'agit de
proposer de repousser l'entrée en
vigueur de l'obligation de présentation
du pass sanitaires à la date du 30
septembre ou à défaut du 15 septembre
ces amendements visent à laisser le
temps aux personnes qui ont fait le
choix ou qui vont faire le choix de
s'engager dans un parcours bac final de
le mener à son terme étant entendu qu'il
ne maîtrise pas le calendrier des
créneaux de vaccination n'est encore la
quantité de doses disponibles
on ne peut pas exiger de quelqu'un
qu'ils remplissent une obligation si on
ne lui laisse pas le temps matériel de
satisfaire à cette obligation
merci monsieur des coeurs dont vous avez
présenté le 71 et le 143e 165 donc le
143 monsieur gosselin merci monsieur le
président oui pour donner un petit peu
de temps au temps mais sans en donner de
trop puisque effectivement la maladie
est bien là on propose de décaler au 15
septembre
le délai de mise en place du pass
évidemment un amendement de repli
on a tout un tas de nos concitoyens un
nombre important de nos concitoyens qui
ne peuvent pas aujourd'hui se faire
vacciner compte tenu des rendez-vous et
si on veut avoir une chaîne de
vaccination qui tienne la route ça nous
paraît raisonnable maintenant j'entends
les arguments qui ont déjà été
développées et je ne serai pas plus loin
même si dans cette discussion commune ya
d'évidentes hic le 50 c'est moi
oui monsieur le président on va c'est la
déclinaison de l'amendement de mes
collègues vous proposant également
l'entrée en vigueur du passionné
sanitaires pour le 15 septembre
mc et le 54 même d'afrique
oui merci monsieur le président comme
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure mais ce le fut
remise à part l'aberration de se passer
ni terre et le désastre économique qui
va provoquer ça permet de repousser la
mise en application au 15 septembre
merci le fond 20 me fait chier le berger
oui merci monsieur le président le pass
sanitaires il existe déjà dans un
certain nombre conditionnée à un certain
nombre de d'éléments que nous avions
discuté en mai en disant hors de la vie
courante
ce hors de la vie courante jusqu'à hier
c'était les grands rassemblements plus
de 1000 personnes
et depuis hier avec effet aujourd'hui
par décret c'est à partir de 50
c'est ce que nous avions voté en mai
c'est la mobilisation au maximum de ce
que nous vous avions permis de faire au
mois de mai c'est déjà de grandes
restrictions à la libre circulation pour
les français elles sont acceptables du
point de vue de l'assemblée nationale
puisque nous avons voté en mai
là vous demander de pouvoir aller plus
loin dans les actes de la vie courante
sauf que vous ne laissez pas hot
français le temps de s'adapter au
calendrier que vous avez posé et à ces
nouvelles règles
parce que les français qui vont se faire
vacciner dans les prochaines semaines
ils n'ont pas été réfractaire jusque là
ils n'ont pas eu accès tout simplement
parce que pour beaucoup d'entre eux ça
s'est ouvert tardivement pour beaucoup
d'entre eux il n'était pas prioritaire
et donc pour beaucoup d'entre eux on
envoyait le signal dans les choix
politiques que nous faisions que ce
n'était pas si urgent que ça qu'ils se
vaccine et bien pour respecter
finalement cette petite incohérence du
message qui leur a été envoyée on peut
aussi accepter qu'un français qui se
mettrait dans un parcours vaccinale
aujourd'hui puissent continuer à
bénéficier du
gym en vigueur jusque là tant que tant
qu' il finisse son parcours vaccinale
est que à partir du 15 septembre lorsque
tout le monde aura fini ce parcours
vaccinale il y ait des restrictions
supplémentaires de la vie courante les
restaurants le commerce de proximité
c'est ça c'est ça l'esprit de cet
amendement c'est juste le respect dû aux
français de bonne foi qui acceptent de
se faire vacciner lim qui veulent se
faire vacciner mais qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas si bien défendu merci le 69 a été
déjà présentés par monsieur dekker le
252 défendu le 337 n'est pas défendu
quand vous défendez monsieur les coeurs
vous êtes deuxième signataire voilà très
bien le 350 si ce monsieur est ménagé
défendu monsieur le fur le 663 défendu
non mais franchement c'est l'évidente
hic monsieur le président précisément je
crois qu'il faut rajouter un argument
majeur me semble-t-il c'est que pour un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes qui
sont dans le commerce qui sont dans des
activités de cafés de restaurants c'est
la saison estivale qui fait leurs
revenus ils vivent de ça ils sont pas
fonctionnaires ils n'ont pas un revenu
garanti
donc s'ils n'ont pas cette capacité de
travailler s'ils perdent leur clientèle
si la suivre d'affaires diminue et bien
pour certains d'entre eux ce sera très
grave tout ça intervient après des mois
de difficultés
eh bien nous nous considérons que ses
compatriotes là il faut les protéger
il ya ses compatriotes là c'est exige
quelques semaines de plus
accordons leur ces quelques semaines qui
leur permettront d'avoir non pas une
saison estivale une année où ils auront
pu travailler correctement
merci le 21 monsieur cordier défendu
merci le sens car 9 me gosselin défendu
monsieur le une discussion commune le 55
va la mettre à four hills a dépendu
merci le monsieur projet le 88
merci monsieur projet le 146 monsieur
gosselin défendu le 253 n'est pas
défendu monsieur manager le 358 défendu
monsieur ciotti le 739 très bien défendu
et madame ménard le 757 merci je
préviens très rapidement parce
qu'effectivement le sens de la ram en a
déjà été défendue mais moi je propose la
date du 1er septembre et je leur
proposerai dans d'autres amendements
pour autre chose parce que depuis les
annonces du président emmanuel macron on
entend remonter beaucoup de la part des
populations de la population française
qu'ils se perdent complètement dans le
calendrier que vous avez indiquée
puisqu'il ya des dispositions qui sont
entrées en vigueur aujourd'hui
d'autres qui vont entrer en vigueur au
1er août d'autres 30 août
d'autres 15 septembre et encore d'autres
37 ans et plus personne ne s'y retrouve
je pense qu'il faut avoir une cohérence
dans le calendrier est peut-être choisir
une date unique pour l'entrée en vigueur
des différentes dispositions géomètre et
le 829 monsieur qu est un illustre par
un cas concret dans nos territoires
ruraux je vais vous démontrer que la
précipitation de l'instauration du pain
sanitaires et d'une grave erreur
alors que la promotion des circuits
courts pour nos produits agro nîmes
alimentaire est une priorité à partager
sur nos bancs alors que nos producteurs
locaux en fruits légumes et autres
produits fermiers sont déjà durement
frappée par la fermeture des instants
awards par la météo
voilà que vos nouvelles mesures
gouvernementales imposent dès
aujourd'hui pour un problème de
responsabilité d'annuler la très grande
majorité de nos marchés locaux estivaux
de plein air les municipalités et autres
organisateurs n'étant pas en capacité de
clôturer ces vieux ouvert
et ainsi de vérifier les passes
sanitaires à l'entrée alors que ne
produit que comptait sur la présence de
nos touristes dans nos belles provinces
touristique touristique on a d'ailleurs
tous risques on a d'ailleurs incité à
rester en france voilà un nouveau coup
de massue pour la survie de nos artisans
producteurs et agriculteurs
nous sommes nombreux à considérer que le
port du masque lors du déplacement sur
ces marchés locaux serait une solution
et en a donc à l'extérieur
l'instauration de votre passage du ter
est tout à fait inadaptée et monsieur le
ministre a évoqué mardi dernier lors de
la question des plus âgés alors sa
langue a peut être un peu fou che mais
moi j'ai bien compris qu'il attendait de
nous qu'on a mais des améliorations lors
des débats en voilà un exemple alors
tout à l'heure vous aviez dit que le
problème est réglé mais sioniste pour
les corps pour les marchés donc locaux
ce n'est pas vrai demain dans ma
circoncision de m'asseoir devait avoir
lieu un marché qui a été annulé parce
que monsieur maire a eu des instructions
strictes par le dl par le préfet du haut
rhin qui lui a dit que vous portez la
peau c'est la responsabilité en cas
d'actes austère temps messieurs ministre
a expliqué nous cette position merci le
870 défendu monsieur matin merci et veut
c'est subtil 723 merci monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président on compte
tenu des prévisions épidémiologique je
pense qu'il ne faut absolument pas
perdre de temps que ce soit un avis
défavorable pour tous ses amendements
merci monsieur le ministre
merci alors j'ai dans les deux demandes
de parole madame le pen
le rapport de la mise en oeuvre du
planétaire au 15 septembre est
évidemment logique d'autant que je
voudrais quand même attirer votre
attention sur la situation des jeunes
des jeunes qui ont été confinés isolé
précarisés qui pour beaucoup se
retrouvent séparés de leur famille qui
ont développé des problèmes
psychologiques lourd pendant longtemps
on leur a expliqué qu'ils n'avaient pas
besoin en réalité d'être vacciné même
lorsque le vaccin serait à disposition
parce que leurs bénéfices risques ne
justifiez pas cette vaccination
ils ont eu des examens au mois de juin
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles
et puis aujourd'hui vous venez leur dire
la chose la plus injuste qui puisse
exister
vous venez leur dire même si ils se font
vacciner aujourd'hui ou demain ou dans
une semaine pour peu qu'ils trouvent de
la place
eh bien ils ne pourront pas vivre
normalement leur était caresse pas moins
de cinquante jours seront nécessaires
avant qu'il puisse avoir accès à des
activités de la vie quotidienne avant
qu'il puisse aller faire du sport avant
qu'il puisse aller sur la terrasse d'un
café
et bien je vous le dit monsieur le
ministre il s'agit là les gars de notre
jeunesse d'une profonde injustice et il
serait tout à fait légitime que l'on
reporte ce délai au 15 septembre pour
que ceux qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner
puisse le faire mais qu' ils ne soient
pas sanctionnés d'un comportement qu'ils
cherchent à avoir mais qui nécessite un
temps minimum de 50 journaux mons parle
merci monsieur aubert non mais c'est
cattin c'est un orateur par groupe
oui non mais un orateur pas loupé c'est
monsieur robert parole en tant que élus
d'un territoire touristique qui est en
train de vivre son pic touristique le
vaucluse
josé cambou signaler que le choix de la
date n'est pas anodin pendant que nous
discutons nous avons des restaurateurs
des hôteliers des activités touristiques
ont beaucoup souffert pendant plusieurs
mois et qui sont en train de gérer
les six mois terminés chers collègues et
qui sont en train de gérer des flux
importants des flux important de
touristes et ils font leurs saisons
maintenant
il l'a fort entre le 1er juillet et le
30 août alors leur mettre des contrôles
sanitaires au beau milieu d'une saison
touristique d'abord leur problème numéro
un c'est de trouver de la main d'oeuvre
d'accord est d'arriver à faire
fonctionner leur entreprise et
deuxièmement c'est parfaitement
inapplicable sur le terrain peut-être
pour quelques grosses structures mais
pour les petites structures c'est
impossible
le décaler de trois semaines ça
permettrait justement de leur faire
passer la saison
mais quand vous expliquer si vous croyez
vraiment que le choix d'une date en
plein milieu du mois d'août va vous
permettre de contrôler l'épidémie va
écouter un moment donné venait un jour
de grand rush dans un restaurant dans un
hôtel dans une structure touristique en
plein milieu du mois d'août
et si vous arrivez à contrôler quoi que
ce soit eh ben je vous souhaite bonne
chance
merci alors tout le monde s'est exprimé
longuement sur ces amendements alors le
sens santé oms de monsieur dekker avis
défavorable de monsieur le ministre l
monsieur le rapporteur qui est pour et
qui est contre volonté le 143 de
monsieur gosselin même avis qui est pour
et qui est contre
redoutée ensuite les identique le 50
monsieur mac et qui est pour et qui est
contre royauté ensuite le 20e monsieur
cordier même avis qui est pour et qui
est contre rejeté le 149 de monsieur
gosselin qui et pour qui contre rejeté
le 55 de madame trastour isnard même
avis et pour qui contre royauté enfin le
743 dessus ciotti mais ma vie qui est
pour et qui est contre rejeté sur
mes chers collègues le président de
l'assemblée a reçu du ministre délégué
chargé des relations avec le parlement
une lettre l'informant que la discussion
du projet de loi relatif à la gestion de
la crise sanitaire se poursuivra demain
matin après midi et soir
la lecture définitive du projet de loi
relatif à la prévention d'actes de
terrorisme et aux renseignements
initialement prévue demain matin aura
lieu à 15 heures d'examen des autres
textes initialement inscrit à l'ordre du
jour du 22 juillet est reportée au
vendredi 23 juillet
prochaine séance demain à 9 heures suite
du projet de loi relatifs à la gestion
de la crise sanitaire
la séance est levée